awesome all at this altitude I can on
flat out for a half-mile before my hands
start shaking and I also support
cybernetic organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by Alibaba and the
Gateway 17 event this is very cool so
listen up if you are an entrepreneur or
business owner in the United States the
stars don't always align that this might
get close all right
the opportunity is this the gateway 17
event which 17 is 2017 is hosted by
Alibaba and Alibaba if you don't know it
you could think of as a combination of
Amazon and Google in China it is huge
this event is designed specifically to
help you guys tap into the 500 million
consumers in the Chinese market they're
fast growing middle class is larger than
the entire US population Alibaba has
created a marketplace better technology
to help you connect with the people you
want to connect with it was 500 million
and now they were looking for us-based
businesses to fill the demand the
Gateway 17 event is designed to help
match make and educate you teacher
everything you need to know the speakers
include Jack Ma who is the founder of
Alibaba he has an estimated net worth of
more than 20 billion dollars this is his
only speaking appearance in 2017 david
Abney the CEO of UPS charlie rose and
more it's a two-day event it's in
Detroit Michigan June 20 and 21st and it
puts you in direct contact with experts
who want to help you grow your business
specifically to access the 500 million
in China and is a listener of this
podcast there is a very legit offer
which more sponsors would offer this
type of discount Alibaba is offering you
the normal tickets which are $500 for
one hundred and twenty five dollars that
is a seventy five percent discount if
you sign up by May
25th so if you sign up by May 25th you
can get a $500 ticket for $125 if you
use the code Tim at checkout that's
capital T lowercase I M you might have
to try all lowercase or all caps but to
start with capital T lowercase I am so
check it out just the website alone
teaches you a lot about the Chinese
middle class and this new consumer base
which has incredible purchasing power I
happen to know a decent amount about it
go to gateway 17 dot-com that's gateway
the number-17 comm and enter the code
Tim at checkout that's gateway 17
dot-com there are a limited number of
spots and it is a low cost event with
potentially very very high upside for
the right folks so check it out gateway
17 dot-com and use code Tim this episode
is brought to you by WordPress my go-to
platform for blogging writing online
creating websites everything I love
WordPress to bits my site every site
just about that I have is run on
WordPress and the lead developer of
WordPress Matt Mullenweg
has appeared on this podcast many times
the very first episode in particular is
amazing the second I took a ton of notes
on so you should check it out but
WordPress where do I even begin I mean
the New Yorker uses it jay-z Beyonce
they use it 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN time
whether you are looking to create a
personal blog a business site both
neither something else you'll make a
huge impact when you build your website
on wordpress.com and directly from some
friends at Google I'm not going to quote
them by name but they say that WordPress
offers the best out-of-the-box SEO the
search engine optimization imaginable so
if you're on WordPress you immediately
have a leg up on everybody else on
search engines and so forth in my
experience I'm no medical doctor of
search engine optimization but I will
say that I used WordPress for years and
fell in love with it too
the extent that I became very close
friends with Matt and then became an
investor / advisor to automatic which
runs WordPress comm that is how much I
believe in this and that's how a lot of
my most successful products and
investments have come about because I'm
in love with X and then I seek out X
nearly 30% of the Internet is run on
WordPress and that includes everything
from the huge sites that I mentioned to
neighborhood sites and it is super easy
to get started there's no need to worry
about security or upgrades or hosting
they offer 24/7 support and handle all
of that which allows you to focus on
creating the highest quality content you
can with the least amount of friction I
don't have to worry about downtime I
don't have to worry about getting
emergency emails if I'm on vacation or
something like that and WordPress is my
go-to solution for all of this I trust
all of my most important text on the
Internet to WordPress and they can't buy
that with a sponsorship they can't buy
that with anything I want uptime uptime
uptime and quality and that is what I
have selected after everything that I've
looked at so check it out go to
WordPress that's wor DP re SS com
wordpress.com for slash Tim to receive
15% off of your website today
that's wordpress.com forward slash PIM
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job each
in every episode to deconstruct
world-class performers of all different
types whether from chess athletics
entertainment military otherwise to
tease out the habits routines favorite
books and so on that you can cast and
apply in your own life this episode is a
little bit different by popular request
we have Rhonda Patrick PhD at found my
fitness on the socials who is an
American biochemist and scientist now
whether you want to extend life
inexpensively buy a stem-cell insurance
policy you may have read about that in
tools of titans or guard against cancer
Rhonda has some very valuable insights
and experiences as well as
recommendations
in this episode she tackles many of your
most popular requested topics this
includes many things I've talked about
before that you guys have wanted more
detail and specifics on best practices
for fasting for instance what blood
tests are most important for analyzing
overall health the minimum effective
dose for the benefits of sauna and
different types of heat exposure heat
versus cold exposure we've talked about
cold baths before how can they be used
and how should they be used effectively
the most effective smart drugs no
tropics thousands of you have asked me
for this the latest fat loss research
and much much more a little background
on Ronda she is known for her studies of
the mechanistic link between vitamin D
and serotonin production research that
may have important implications for the
understanding of autism and other
disorders and she also has a very
popular podcast found Myatt Fitness dr.
Patrick also conducts clinical trials
has performed aging research at the Salk
Institute for Biological studies and did
graduate research at st. Jude's
Children's Research Hospital which I've
had some involvement with where she
focused on cancer mitochondrial
metabolism and apoptosis so I hope you
enjoy this conversation which is really
a master class with Ronda Patrick as
much as I did thanks for listening
hi guys Rhonda Patrick here happy to be
here today to get things started let's
take an opening question from Tim
Ferriss Tim asks what new areas
experiments discoveries or hypotheses
are you most excited about these days
thankfully because I put a certain
percentage of my brain out here on the
Internet much of what I'm actively
interested in these days or have been
interested in is actually lucid ated a
little bit as necessary context for some
of the questions I'm going to answer
here shortly but Tim's question does
sort of give a nice opportunity for an
overview as a rule the things that
usually get me really revved up are
ultimately optimizations that we can
make to our lifestyles that might
increase our functional health span our
well-being and lastly cognitive and
physical performance usually through
deeper understandings of biology health
span or healthy functional life span is
especially of interest to me I sort of
lead with that
to me health span is living
for as long as we can while doing our
best to prevent deterioration from the
diseases of aging talking about
increasing health fun is one thing
though often achieving it is a different
thing altogether the reason this is
tricky is that the most reliable way to
treat aging is to try to instead prevent
it a natural extension of that fact
means that the earlier we start the
better shot we have of making a large
cumulative effect over the course of our
lives now the specifics of how to best
mitigate the damaging effects of aging
specifically is subject to a little bit
of individual variation as a consequence
of each of our little genetic indio sync
receives the combination of which are
unique to each of us this is an area
that I'm especially interested in and
that I plan to invest a little bit more
into intellectually in the coming months
especially the interface between
nutrition and genetics known as
nutrigenomics but the good news is there
are certain rule of thumb strategies
that are able to have a positive effect
on health and possibly even longevity in
some cases it might mean optimizing our
diet around inclusion of specific
nutrients one of the most interesting
and exciting of which to me right now is
a compound known as sulforaphane
spelled sul f o ra pH ane but also other
related compounds that fall into the
same class of compounds broadly known as
Isis IO sign aids all of which including
sulfur f---ing being derived from
cruciferous vegetables what's
interesting about sulfur cream is that
this compound richly found in broth is
frost at about fifty to a hundred times
what's found in mature broccoli is that
it activates a special genetic pathway
in ourselves known as nrf2 and it does
so more potently than any other known
naturally-occurring dietary compound
this gene a master regulator controls
over 200 other genes affecting whether
or not they're activated and doing work
these include genes that are affect our
own anti inflammatory processes
antioxidant processes and even the
ability to inactivate potentially
harmful compounds that were exposed to
on a daily basis from breeding and
carcinogens like benzene from air
pollution in a sense we're talking about
an on switch from some of our most
native stress responses our ability to
cope with physiological stress down to
the cellular level ultimately affects
how rapidly we accumulate the damage
which we often refer to as aging but and
here's the interesting thing
the reason interrupt
to a stress response pathway is
activated by solar vane is because the
compound itself functions as what we
know as a Zeno hormetic a compound that
by virtue of being actually slightly
stressful to self elicits a biological
stress response that has a cumulative
effect that is otherwise a net gain and
resilience that creates a benefit to the
organism as a whole this is actually
somewhat unintuitive if you really think
about that we sort of had this very
natural notion that because excess
stress is bad we should venture to avoid
stress at all costs it turns out though
that in fact perhaps as a consequence of
having received stressful compounds in
our diets for millions of years things
that evolved in plants such as insect
antecedents that help ward off insects
we sometimes function better for having
them they can even induce neuro stress
responses that boost neuro trophic
factors that lead to the growth of new
neurons and promote the survival of
existing neurons which may function to
help make compounds like sulforaphane
potentially a candidate as a mild
nootropic we'll probably come back to
this in a little bit but the bottom line
is is that if we take this same concept
that stress can be beneficial known as
hormesis and apply to other things like
exercise fasting heat stress cold stress
some of the various benefits that may be
had from these many strategies
similarly come about as a consequence of
sometimes overlapping stress response
pathways this idea of hormesis and
trying to improve our capacity to be
resilient to environmental stress and
even the stress generated as a byproduct
of normal metabolism and immune function
in particular is a very useful framework
for evaluating the potential strategies
that might have promise in preventing
even aging okay all of that said this is
a great opportunity to jump from these
sort of big picture ideas back to things
of a more practical application variety
specifically the next question evaluates
a straightforward technique that has
caught my interest and also happens to
be broadly applicable to almost anyone
all right
so Brandon Beckett asks dr. Rhonda
Patrick you interviewed dr. Valter Longo
doctor Sachin panda and dr. Ruth
Patterson on time restricted feeding and
fasting can you summarize your best
practices for time restricted eating and
who it might not be a good fit for okay
this is a fun question but before we
dive right into best practices on time
research
eating it probably helps to know what it
is for the rest of you that may be
listening time restricted eating as it's
called in humans or time restricted
feeding as it's referred to an animal
research is this idea that pit
constraining our eating within a certain
time window during the day ranging from
only 8 hours up to 12 hours per day
usually earlier in the day to align
better with our circadian rhythm we
stand to benefit from a variety of
different angles on the more extreme end
of eight hours you're engaging in a
slightly more extreme type of time
restrictive eating which is more well
known in the fitness world in particular
as 16-8 intermittent fasting simply
maintaining a slightly more conservative
time window than you usually might have
started to show advantages as well
potentially functioning as a lifestyle
intervention that may be able to protect
people from obesity metabolic related
disease and more at the population level
for example even an 11 hour eating
window has been associated in one study
with a reduced risk of breast cancer and
potentially recurrence by as much as 36
percent in women we'll get back to what
the research both mouse and human says
about the duration of the time windows
involved but first let's talk a little
bit about the circadian aspect when
healthy adults eat meals that are
identical in terms of both their macro
nutrient and caloric content at
breakfast lunch or dinner
the postprandial glucose increase is a
lowest after breakfast and highest after
dinner even though the meals were a
hundred percent identical this is just
one example that suggests metabolism
changes throughout the day we also know
that in humans metabolic genes are more
active during the day and less active at
night the underlying reason for this is
because humans are diurnal creatures
which means that we conduct most of our
activities during the day including
feeding exercising and working and then
resting at night what makes humans
diurnal creatures is the presence of an
internal clock in the brain referred to
as the suprachiasmatic nucleus or SCN
for short the part of this internal
clock that interacts with the external
cue of light the Sen is also referred to
as the master oscillator but light isn't
the only external cue we have we also
have food influencing what are known as
peripheral oscillators that occur in
peripheral tissues such as the liver and
influenced metabolism
whereas light is a major to four
circadian rhythm timing of food intake
regulates circadian rhythm in peripheral
tissues as well this fax sort of helps
to explain
why time restricted eating as its
defined by dr. panda's work and that of
others begins with the eating period
with the very first bite or drink of
anything non water because even
compounds that exist in black coffee
such as caffeine can be reasonably
expected to produce metabolic effects
that influence these peripheral
oscillators including activity in the
liver everything from making
neurotransmitters to insulin to glucose
transport inside of cells to oxidizing
fatty acids to repairing damage is on a
24-hour cycle clock that is influenced
by these external cues involving
metabolism to sort of illustrate the
importance of circadian rhythm these
clocks regulate thousands and thousands
of genes which is somewhere in the
neighborhood of around 10 to 15 percent
of the expressed human genome which
means that our much basic metabolic
physiology is meant to be tuned to
behave differently depending on the time
of day that it is even the bacteria that
we Harbor on our guts have a circadian
rhythm with the species of bacteria
changing according to the time of day
some bacteria dominate during the
morning and others during the evening
unfortunately with the invention of
artificial lighting and the varying work
schedules it has extended people's
eating times to occur much later in the
evening and this can have very negative
consequences eating late at night may
also reset peripheral clocks and result
in misalignment of metabolism which
means when you wake up your metabolism
is already at the end of its cycle so
that's the logic behind the circadian
aspect which gets left out of some of
the intermittent fasting philosophies
that are popular and explains why time
restrictive eating emphasizes an earlier
eating window and includes non-caloric
xenobiotics as breaking the fast
something I've learned is a specific
point of contention for people okay but
shifting away from the xenobiotics and
circadian aspects to talk more about the
time window itself animals that have
been limited to a 9 to 12 hour feeding
window in which they can eat but
otherwise allowing them to eat the same
amount of calories that they normally
would they have shown that they can
attain some pretty amazing benefits
including decreased fat mass increased
lean muscle mass improved glucose
tolerance improved lipid profile reduced
inflammation higher mitochondrial volume
protection from mild age-related fatty
liver protection from obesity generally
favourable improvements in gene
expression and increased production of
ketone bodies which is interesting for
another reason we'll go back to in a
minute time restriction eating also has
a growing body of
research in humans recent studies
suggest that mentioned briefly earlier
eating within an 11 hour window was
associated with a decreased breast
cancer risk and reduction in recurrence
by as much as 36 percent earlier meal
timing associates with improved
effectiveness of weight-loss therapy in
overweight and obese people for each
three hour increase in night time
fasting duration was linked with a 20%
lower odds of elevated glycated
hemoglobin hba1c which say more
long-term marker for blood glucose
levels for each 10% increase in the
proportion of calories consumed after 5
p.m. there was a 3% increase in the
inflammatory biomarkers c-reactive
protein otherwise known as CRP eating
one additional meal during a day instead
of the evening was associated with an 8%
decrease in c-reactive protein eating
within a 12-hour window improved sleep
and increased weight loss in normal
weight people as a rule of thumb
anything that has the potential to
mitigate chronic systemic inflammation
is something I personally consider worth
trying to dial in cents suppression of
inflammation is thought to be one of the
most important predictors of successful
longevity that increases importance with
advancing age and also influences the
risk of cancer and even potentially
mental health so putting aside the
potential to have better blood glucose
control or protect myself from obesity
without actually changing the
composition of my diet reducing systemic
inflammation has a lot of appeal to me
now that we are all on the same page in
terms of what some of the research shows
on the benefits of time restricted
eating I would like to go back and
address Brandon's question about what my
best practices are surrounded time
restricted eating how you choose to
implement some of this information is
ultimately going to be dictated by life
circumstances that include practical
realities surrounding work schedule and
probably a million other things the
flexibility of my schedule however has
made implementing time restrictive
eating admittedly a bit easier unless I
have a social reason that forces me to
eat later in the day I usually start my
clocks as soon as I wake up thus I don't
concern myself a whole lot about what
counts as breaking the fasts and what
doesn't and I go by the strictest of
definitions if it's not water it breaks
the fast unless it's just brushing my
teeth I don't count that if I wake up at
8 a.m. and have my first tip of coffee
at 8:15 then I make a note to myself or
I set an alarm on my phone
one and a half hours before the clock
ends which is usually around 6:15 p.m.
since I aim for around a 10 hour eating
window and a 14 hour nighttime fasting
window when I'm feeling especially
motivated I eat within an 8 or 9 hour
time window and fast for 15 or 16 hours
during the night which means if I have
my first sip of coffee at 8:15 a.m. then
I stop eating by either 4:15 or 5:15
p.m. I follow the same procedure on days
I sleep in
even though animal research shows that
this pattern has benefits even if you
cheat on the weekend now the reason why
I chose a 10 hour window is because it's
a sufficiently tight window of time to
likely confer some of the advantages of
time restricted eating without being
unduly burdensome personal compliance
here being the issue stretching for the
nine hour or even eight hour window
however can be also be interesting and
may appeal to some some animal research
has shown that a certain aerobic
endurance benefit for time restricted
feeding in this nine hour range but not
for shorter fasts and if you think about
it my said only feed for nine hour
periods and are fasting for the other 15
hours it makes sense it takes around 10
to 12 hours for liver glycogen stores to
be depleted which is then followed by
fatty acids being liberated from adipose
tissue these fatty acids are then
transported to the liver where they are
converted into ketone bodies like beta
hydroxy butyrate which are then
transported to a wide variety of other
tissues such as the muscle and used for
energy so it sort of makes sense that
eating within a nine-hour window and
fasting for 15 hours overnight may lead
to endurance enhancements if we've
managed to kick off a little more ketone
production the evening before a run
anecdotally I've observed that
personally I feel an improvement in
endurance ranging from slight to pretty
significant in my morning runs when I've
tried a little bit harder to eat
strictly within an eight or nine hour
time window just as a closing thought I
think there is still a lot of room for
more emerging research in this area to
teach us things that may be important
questions like what influenced later day
endurance or weight training has on
mitigating the deleterious effects of
other suboptimal parameters like a later
in the day eating window how large the
effect of xenobiotics like caffeine and
black coffee is compared to potentially
more important factor like just keeping
an otherwise tighter time window with a
slightly looser definition of what is
considered eating if you'd like to see
interesting questions answered about
time restricted eating you can actually
participate in a mobile app powered
distributed clinical trial by heading
over to dr. Sachin pandas lab website
which can be found at my circadian clock
org available for iPhone and Android
basically you commit to a baseline and
then one of the patterns of time
restricted eating and then proceed to
submit time-stamped pictures of your
food over the course of 12 weeks of
course I'd also be remiss if I didn't
mention that a mutual friend and someone
has repeatedly been on the Tim Ferriss
show Kevin Rose has developed a cool
mobile app to help keep track of
intermittent fasting and time restricted
eating windows you can also check that
out if you're an iPhone user it's in the
App Store under the name zero as in the
number of calories you consume while
fasting to sort of finish off this
question as for who time restricted
feeding may not be a good fit for I'm
not sure as an intervention I believe it
is actually broadly applicable however
I'm 100% certain that there is someone
somewhere for which a unique medical
condition may make time restrictive
eating inappropriate especially if you
expand the definition of time restricted
eating to me long multi-day fast which
is the subject of dr. vulture Longo's
research in particular definitely check
in with the position particularly if
you're going to do a prolonged fast or
if you're thinking of trying time
restricted eating but may have a medical
condition that for some reason might
somehow make it unsafe okay next
question
Josh kissing asks for all those that
don't understand the benefits of fasting
how does doing it fast differ from say
eating a diet low carb high fat that
puts you into ketosis and what key
metrics for example blood tests should
someone look at to know it is benefiting
you very interesting question because as
implied by the question there are at
least a few similarities between a low
carb high fat diet and fasting but there
are also obviously some key differences
probably the main similarity between the
two is that metabolism shifts from using
glucose as the major source of energy to
primarily oxidation of fatty acids and
ketone bodies as energy when it comes to
fasting there are a few things that
really differentiate it from a low carb
high fat diet one of the major benefits
of fasting particularly prolonged
fasting which is around four to five
days in humans that is not found on a
low-carb high-fat diet is a dramatic
increase in Itachi and apoptosis
followed by a massive
in stem cell production a Chava G is a
genetic program that is very important
it clears away damaged cells to use for
energy while apoptosis is a genetic
program that causes damaged cells to
self-destruct both of these processes
prevent damaged cells from becoming
cancer cells when we clear away damaged
cells this also means those cells are
less likely to become senescent which is
what can happen when too much damage
accumulates a senescence cell is
technically a living cell but it is not
functioning in a way that is consistent
with maintaining the overall health of
an organ in fact quite the opposite
senescence cells can accelerate the
aging of nearby cells and promote tumor
growth by secreting pro-inflammatory
molecules and other factors senescence
cells are bad news as we age they are
everywhere from our livers to our hearts
to our brains and they accelerate the
aging process it has been shown in mice
when given a compound that increases the
clearance of senescent cells it actually
extends your average lifespan by 20%
another way that fasting really shines
particularly prolonged fasting is that
prolonged fasting has a very robust
effect on increasing stem cell numbers
the regenerative power of tissues and
organs decline with age it is stem cells
that provide this regenerative power and
because stem cell numbers decline with
age so does organ function which means
anything that can counter this is a wind
fasting also causes cells to clear away
damaged mitochondria and recycle their
defective components for energy called
maitake followed by a concomitant
generation of new mitochondria called
mitochondrial biogenesis this is a
really great thing because mitochondria
accumulate damage with age just as cells
do and this can accelerate the aging
process so not only does fasting clear
away old damaged mitochondria it also
generates new young a healthy
mitochondria to replace the damaged ones
there has also been some evidence that
suggesting that a low-carb high-fat diet
may modestly increase mitochondrial
biogenesis as well but not my toffee gee
another thing fasting does is it
increases the levels of something called
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide or nad
Plus which I will just refer to as nad
nad levels always increase during a
fasted State and decrease during the fed
State no matter what food type nad is a
very important cofactor for many
metabolic enzymes
which just means you need it for these
enzymes to work properly your
mitochondria I need nad to produce
energy from glucose or fatty acids
anytime there is chronic inflammation or
DNA damage occurring this sucks up the
nad and so the mitochondria suffer also
nad levels decrease in multiple tissues
with aging there are several different
compounds which are various forms of
vitamin b3 that dramatically increase
nad levels and have been shown to delay
aging in multiple tissues in mice yet
another difference between fasting and a
low-carb high-fat diet is that fasting
activates many repair processes
including repair of damaged DNA damaged
cells damaged mitochondria and damaged
proteins you must be in a fasted state
to repair damage which is why most
repair processes occur during sleep
because that is when most people are in
a fasted State fasting improves blood
sugar insulin sensitivity and blood
lipids and improves inflammatory markers
including c-reactive protein and tumor
necrosis factor also known as TNF alpha
and improves adiponectin leptin and
brain-derived neurotropic factor in
humans a low-carb high-fat diet has also
been shown to improve blood glucose and
insulin levels and also reduce
inflammation but not always consistently
and may be highly variable depending on
the individual which is likely due to
the fact that the way our bodies respond
to food is also complicated by genetics
we have variations in our genes that
make them operate a little differently
from similar versions in other members
of the human population these variations
are known as genetic polymorphisms one
of the best examples I have seen yet
demonstrating the immense variability
and how people respond to the same foods
was a publication that came out in 2015
in the journal Cell the study looked at
the blood glucose responses of over 800
different people to various foods
including fat without getting into all
the details of this study what is
important the topic of this discussion
is that while most people had a low
glucose response to dietary fat some
people had a high glucose response there
have even been a few important gene
polymorphisms that have been identified
to play a role in the context of a
high-fat diet such as sto P P R alpha P
P R gamma and apoe4
PP R alpha is one of the most important
genes that I'll mention because it plays
a very
role in the process of ketogenesis
activation of PPR alpha promotes uptake
utilization and catabolism the fatty
acids by activating genes involved in
fatty acid transport fatty acid binding
and activation and fatty acid oxidation
there is a polymorphism in this gene
that has been associated with lower PPI
or alpha activity and a two-fold higher
risk of type 2 diabetes increased levels
of triglycerides increased total
cholesterol increased LDL cholesterol
and especially important increase small
dense LDL particles in the context of
high saturated fat intake and low
polyunsaturated fat intake obviously
measuring these blood biomarkers will
help illuminate whether any type of diet
works for you there are also a variety
of resources on the web link and help
you take your raw genetic data from
services like 23andme and find out
whether you have some of these
polymorphisms i similarly offer some
resources for this on my website found
my fitness comm for this purpose in
terms of biomarkers things that I would
monitor particularly if I were doing a
ketogenic diet might include biomarkers
for lipid and glucose metabolism such as
lvl small dense LDL particles total
cholesterol triglycerides glycated
hemoglobin hba1c you can also measure
your fasting blood glucose levels and
ketone levels at home using something
like precision extra which I find to be
mostly reliable and I also use I also
like to be aware of any inflammatory
biomarkers I can get my hands on through
some common measurements like high
sensitivity to react to protein and also
il-6 and Tina's alpha for those people
experimenting with a strict ketogenic
diet for greater than six months it may
be wise to measure thyroid function by
doing a full thyroid panel there was a
recent publication where a ketogenic
diet for nine months caused thyroid
dysfunction and children with epilepsy
this may not be something to worry about
in everyone but it does not hurt to be
cautious for Tozzi related and stem-cell
related biomarkers there are some used
in research that you unfortunately can't
really get ahold of for self monitoring
purposes for a tapa g/l c-32 and for
stem-cell self-renewal Lyn negative cd18
for positive cd45 of negative cells okay
one quick closing point to sort of
finish this section off it's important
when we talk about fasting that we make
clear distinctions between the various
duration of fast
think about if we discuss prolonged
fasting as I have done a lot in
answering this question that means we're
talking about a water fast on the order
of four to five days
however in Mouse research this level of
fasting is actually achieved in two to
three days this has led to some
confusion because people often attribute
the so-called benefits of prolonged
fasting to shorter intervals that are a
bit more manageable because they might
have ran across this rodent research the
fact is that we may see some of the same
benefits such as a tapa G even with
shorter fast but on an order of
magnitude greater with prolonged fasts
also with a prolonged fast which the
entire organ systems can shrink and then
can experience renewal during the
repeating period so it should be pretty
clear that we're actually talking about
a whole different level of cellular
cleanup that can occur which is above
and beyond what we actually get in
shorter fasts there's still a lot of
research going on to better tease out
the differences between shorter let's
say 2-day fast and fast that meet the
definition of being a prolonged fast I'm
optimistic that evidence will continue
to emerge and that even shorter duration
fasts are still very beneficial that
said as Kim likes to say I'm not a
medical doctor and don't play one on the
internet if you're thinking about giving
prolonged fasting a shot make sure to
follow the prudent podcast listeners
rule and run it by an actual physician
there's also an emerging body of
literature surrounding a fasting
mimicking diet that lasts five days
instead of four and can be prescribed by
a doctor by a packaged meal plan if
having that structure is helpful on to
the next question Jeff Norton asks
Rhonda can you please share your
thoughts on the minimum effective dose
for sauna benefits session time
temperature and frequency from this
minimum effective dose what types of
changes benefits can someone expect with
this question I'm going to start with
the benefit sense of a point of logical
progression it's helpful to establish
what the science says about the benefits
before we talk about how to dose it the
good news is I've actually partly done a
pretty good job of talking about some
potential benefits for sauna use and a
guest post that's featured on Tim's blog
entitled our sauna the next big
performance-enhancing drug it's possible
Jeff's already seen that but for the
rest of you make sure to check that out
since that initial blog post however
some pretty cool research has come out
related to sauna use and it touches on
areas that I spend a lot of time
thinking about well
and also Alzheimer's disease so if you
were me for a minute while I talk about
some of this and then get back to Jess
questions surrounding what the minimum
effective dose might be with respect to
temperature sauna session time and
frequency to elicit some effects that
might be loosely characterized as orgo
genic or enhancing physical performance
in some respects a study published in
JAMA internal medicine in 2015 showed
that sauna use was associated with
longevity the study recruited over 2000
middle-aged men in Finland and compared
frequency of sauna use with sudden
cardiac death fatal coronary heart
disease fatal cardiovascular disease and
all cause mortality including cancer of
the course of 20 years heart disease is
the leading cause of death in the United
States and many other countries as well
so that should be a cue to listen up
here's what the study found that fatal
cardiovascular disease was a twenty
seven percent lower in men who used this
on a two to three times a week and 50%
lower for men who use the sauna forty
seven times per week compared with men
who just used the sauna once a week in
addition to lowering cardiovascular rate
of mortality the study also found the
sauna use lowered all cause mortality
full stop using this on a to three times
per week was associated with a 24% lower
all cause mortality and four to seven
times per week lowered all cause
mortality by forty percent let's talk
about all the cause mortality what does
it mean does it mean that using the
sauna four to seven times per week made
forty percent people immortal no what it
means is that for the individuals being
studied they had 40% less mortality than
those of a similar age not being
subjected to the same conditions and
this reduction in mortality was strictly
tied to heart disease but instead
something potentially more general keep
in mind this study also adjusted for
other parameters that may affect the
data including body mass serum
cholesterol blood pressure smoking
alcohol consumption type 2 diabetes
physical activity and socioeconomic
status we'll come back to talk more
about this generalized lung youngevity
effects in a minute since it's
interesting to discuss plausible
mechanisms that underlie that effect the
effects on heart disease however are a
little more straightforward to try to
explain some of the more positive
benefits of sauna use on heart health
may have to do with similar benefits
seen with regular physical exercise
heart rate can increase up to a hundred
beats per minute during moderate sauna
bathing sessions and up to 150 beats per
minute during more intense warm sauna
use
150 beats per minute corresponds to
moderate intensity physical exercise
which as we already know has a very
positive effect on cardiovascular health
heat stress from sauna youth also
increases plasma volume and blood flow
to the heart known as stroke volume this
results in reduced cardiovascular strain
so that your heart has had less work for
each beat that it does to pump
oxygen-rich blood to your tissues into
your brain
additionally long-term sauna use has
been shown to generally improve blood
pressure and athelia function and left
ventricular function but crossing over
from theory to more practical what-if
improving heart health really just meant
having a boost in endurance in fact that
is exactly what has been demonstrated
one study demonstrated that a 30-minute
sauna session two times a week for three
weeks post-workout increase the time
that it took for the study participants
to run till exhaustion by 32% compared
to baseline if you start to think of
mild adaptation to heat stress as a
proxy for some of the benefits of
exercise
the generalized longevity effect starts
to make sense but there may be molecular
mechanisms for this as well there's two
pathways in particular I'd like to
briefly highlight heat shock proteins
produced by ourselves in response to
heat stress and also another pathway
known as Fox o3 sauna use robustly
activates a class of stress response
proteins known as heat shock proteins
and heat shock proteins have been
implicated in aging where increased
expression has been shown to
mechanistically in lower organisms to
confer increase longevity and similarly
polymorphisms in human populations that
increase heat shock protein production
have also been shown to have an
association with increased longevity to
understand why this is the case it is
helpful to know the purpose of heat
shock proteins also known as HSPs heat
shock proteins help all other proteins
maintain their proper 3-dimensional
structure in the cell which is important
for each protein in order for it to be
able to perform its function its various
interactions that occur disrupt the
structure of that protein for example
denaturing it then this prevents the
protein from doing its function and
changing the half-life of it as I
briefly mentioned earlier damaging
products get created from normal immune
system function and metabolism these
damaging molecules produced at a low
level every day even in the best of
circumstances but made worse by poor
lifestyle choices damaged proteins and
disrupt their structure moreover once
approach
structure is damaged it can then miss
fold preventing it from being degraded
and can lead to the accumulation of
toxic protein aggregates that can
themselves damage cells as well protein
aggregates something heat shock proteins
specifically help prevent the
accumulation of are associated with
neurodegenerative diseases such as
Alzheimer's disease and Parkinson's
disease and Huntington's disease in fact
when you take normal mice that have an
engineer to accumulate amyloid beta
plaques characteristic of alzheimers
disease they do begin to manifest a
pathology in the brain that is similar
to what we might call Alzheimer's in
humans but if you engineer these same
mice to over produce one of the more
well-known heat-shock proteins called
hsp70 it reduces the severity of this
condition including reducing the
associated loss of neurons and synapses
so if you think about it this might
suggest something interesting we know
that heat shock proteins are produced in
response to heat stress and that they
seem to help prevent symptoms of
Alzheimer's disease in mice by reducing
protein aggregation and helping keep
proteins from losing their structure in
the first place what if by naturally
increasing our heat shock protein
expression we could reduce the risk of
Alzheimer's disease the same group that
studied over 2000 ml sauna goers found a
very interesting Association from the
same cohort that they later published in
another paper they found that men that
used this on a 2 to 3 times per week had
a 22% lower risk of dementia and a 20%
lower risk of Alzheimer's disease
compared to men that only uses on a one
time a week men that use this on a four
to seven times a week had a 66 percent
lower risk of dementia and a 65 percent
lower risk of Alzheimer's disease
compared to men that only uses on a once
a week once again just as before
this is after adjustment for age alcohol
consumption body mass index systolic
blood pressure smoking status type 2
diabetes previous myocardial infarction
resting heart rate and serum LDL
cholesterol now whether or not it was
the heat shock proteins may be a great
idea for future research but as a
plausible mechanism heat shock proteins
seem as a very good likely explanation
for what is going on there since we've
also mentioned briefly the endurance and
cardiovascular benefits of sauna youth
particularly in a trial involving run
until exhaustion aerobic activity it's
also worth mentioning that vo2 max
the bodies kept maximum capacity to
transport and use oxygen during exercise
has a strong association with cognitive
capability in old age which may have
something to do with the brain perfusion
and even the ability for blood perfusion
to wash away metabolic waste products
including amyloid beta the other
molecular pathway of interest that may
help explain some of what's going on
with this association between a type of
longevity and sauna youth mentioned
earlier is a pathway known as the Fox o3
pathway there is some evidence that part
of this natural cellular stress response
when confronted with heat is an
activation of this pathway Fox o3 is one
of the big aging genes for which regular
old fashioned genetic variation has
shown is involved in longevity humans
with a polymorphism that make more Fox
o3 have up to a two point seven fold
increased chance of living to be a
centenarian and in mice having more of
their homologous version of this same
gene can extend their lifespan by up to
30% as the pattern of aging our Fox o3
activation trends downward decreasing
expression with age
boxer 3 is a master regulator involved
in etapa G DNA repair metabolism
endogenous antioxidant production stem
cell function and immune function since
we've already spent so much time
navigating the especially relevant
waters of HSPs I'll leave the discussion
of Fox o3 alone for now ok so we got a
little bit distracted talking about
mechanism and other various odds and
ends surrounding sonnies but to return
to part of the core of the question
asked by Jeff we need to address minimum
effective joes for the minimal benefits
of lower cardiovascular disease
mortality lower all cause mortality and
lower Alzheimer's disease risk we have
to address the literature that actually
observed these effects in this case that
would be 20 minutes at 174 degrees
Fahrenheit or 79 degrees Celsius two to
three times per week remember though
that those that use this on a four to
seven times a week had an even more
robust effect this is actually a pretty
great guide because we've got a range of
effects based on dosing in a pretty
large trial of around 2,000 participants
if we turn our attention to smaller
studies such as the run until exhaustion
endurance trial we mentioned earlier the
minimum effective dose for endurance
appear to be 30 minutes in a 194
Fahrenheit or 90 degrees Celsius on it
twice a week a dose which by the way
produce
a maximum heart rate of 140 beats per
minute this last point is especially
interesting if you consider the fact
that maximal heart rate might be an
appealing candidate for quantified
Sulphurs to track their physiological
response to heat stress when other
variables may differ take for example
the fact that not all saunas get is hot
especially the infrared ones that run
cooler
it does seem reasonable to think however
that turning the knobs on other aspects
of the sauna session by making changes
for example to the duration you can
probably still elicit comparable effects
what I have not discussed yet but
mentioned in a guest post on Tim's blog
certain studies have demonstrated some
effects on muscle mass and recovery and
animal and human trials for endocrine
effects in the area of growth hormone
for example multiple studies report
ranges of twenty to thirty minutes
at around 176 degrees Fahrenheit or 80
degrees Celsius in the neighborhood of
two to three times a week again pretty
similar to the larger 2000 person
mortality in Al summer studies mentioned
earlier finally molecular evidence for
heat shock protein induction seems to
indicate that healthy young men and
women sitting in around a hundred and
sixty-three degrees Fahrenheit or around
a seventy three degrees celsius sauna
for thirty minutes are able to increase
their heat shock protein levels
including hsp70 two by forty-nine
percent and that the elevation in heat
shock protein levels persist for 48
hours after the initial heat stress
suggesting two to three times per week
is again a good moderate frequency to
hit a threshold for some of these
sustained effects so it's pretty clear
we have a few options available to us
some more mild than others more popular
here where I live in the United States
are infrared saunas which don't get
quite as hot often limited to about a
hundred and forty degrees Fahrenheit or
sixty degrees Celsius for reasons of
practicality and because I believe that
benefits from the sauna are primarily
conferred directly by heat I tend to
prefer a hotter sauna but it seems
wholly reasonable that making other
adjustments like preceding the sauna
session with the light cardio for
example might help make up for other
little differences it's hard to know for
absolute certain but I'm optimistic all
that said I think it's a good moment to
make a point to give the same warning
Tim gives on his blog surrounding sauna
use and heat stress in general try to
exercise good judgment if you have some
sort of medical
all bets are off even if you don't think
you have a medical condition it's
reasonably worth checking in with a
doctor before becoming some kind of mega
sauna enthusiast heat can be a no-joke
and it's important that you don't hurt
yourself
finally there's other so-called benefits
that I have suggested may exist on Tim's
blog but they didn't get to talk about
today areas where the science may be
promising but not quite as robust or
otherwise confer itself well to talking
about a minimum effective dose including
the possibility that sauna use could
play a role in mood and attention by
increasing norepinephrine and affecting
our sensitivity to and production of
beta endorphin giving us a sort of
runner's high the potential of which was
something that initially appealed to me
when experimenting with my own personal
sauna use or the possibility that sauna
use may reduce muscle atrophy and then
affect muscle regrowth and effect which
while very interesting is mostly shown
in animal studies that might be hard to
then try to apply back to humans so
definitely go check out that post moving
forward we can now talk about the flip
side of the coin with our next question
from senato s'mores he says I would like
to know about the interaction between
heat and cold exposure and if they will
cancel one another out for example if I
do a workout and then sauna for 10 to 20
minutes to engage the heat shock
proteins to maximize the hormonal
response and then proceed to take a cold
shower will that cancel out the benefit
of the sauna and heat exposure also will
that make the cold exposure less
effective for this question I'm going to
choose to focus on discussing the
question of combining heat stress and
cold stress in rapid succession rather
than a discussion of the combination of
either with exercise which is sort of a
different overlapping discussion which
comes up in a different question which
I'll get to in a moment so to answer
this question with our slightly narrowed
parameters I've been trying to find
empirical evidence in the scientific
literature discussing various aspects of
combining heat stress and cold stress
and have come up pretty dry when it
comes to answering a lot of the big
questions surrounding the combination of
both these modalities in rapid
succession frankly it's hard to find
good information whether we're talking
about winter swimming as in s10 by sauna
goers in Finland or simply a cold shower
or far more extreme alternating between
sauna and ice baths as described by Rick
Rubin and
Ferriss during their sauna podcasting
experience one thing we can do a little
bit of however is turn to the molecular
evidence what may surprise many of you
is that both heat stress from the sauna
and even cold stress are both able to
activate heat shock proteins this is
because heat shock proteins respond to
cellular stress in general and not
exclusively heat stress heat as a
cellular stress does cause a more robust
activation than cold though still is
sort of good to know that both types of
thermal stress seems to positively
affect heat shock protein expression
which we sort of established may have
something to do with some of the
benefits we might ascribe to sauna use
but it's sort of important to ask
yourself what you're trying to
accomplish with cold exposure aspect one
of the main reasons I like to expose
myself to cold are the effects it seems
to have on the brain moved and possibly
attention one of the most likely
candidates for eliciting and effect is
norepinephrine which is also the
catecholamine that is actually
responsible for triggering the Browning
of fat making our fat more metabolically
active in fact in terms of pathways or
physiological responses to cold the
release of norepinephrine into the
bloodstream as well as in the locus
karolius region of the brain is one of
the more profound guess what else
increases norepinephrine release heat
from sauna use so this is the second way
in which both hot and cold instead of
having opposing effects where one
cancels out the other at the molecular
level are nudging some of the same
pathways in the same direction but to
elicit these overlapping stress
responses you have to actually get cold
enough for that to happen otherwise
you're just taking some of that heat
burden you created on your own body and
removing it how cold is cold is the real
question we have to ask here in the case
of an ice bath I suspect the stress is
almost certainly additive in nature the
extremes of going from a 200 to reshare
in mind sauna to near freezing water
isn't a walk in the park in the case of
a 30 second cold shower that isn't
sufficient to even trigger momentary
discomfort is probably not adding stress
but in fact simply removing it this
isn't strictly a bad thing if that's
what you're wanting to do that said to
give you an idea for some of the
threshold temperatures involved to
elicit the norepinephrine response of
cold stress studies have shown that
people that immerse themselves in cold
water at 40 degrees Fahrenheit or 4.42
resale see
for 20 seconds increase their
norepinephrine two to threefold or 200
to 300 percent and this release and
norepinephrine didn't seem to be reduced
with habituation to cold long durations
of cold water exposure under more
moderate temperature have a more potent
effect on norepinephrine release for
example in another study people that
spent one hour in 57 degree Fahrenheit
or 14 degrees Celsius water increased
norepinephrine and their blood streams
by 530 percent over baseline as anyone
who I swam in the Pacific Ocean knows
this is still quite cold and certainly
sufficiently uncomfortable but it's
probably very possible depending on
where you live and the season to get a
shower that is similarly cold or even
more cold something I personally observe
that sort of interesting is that after
sufficiently intense sauna session
it can be very hard to stop sweating and
even potentially hours after you cool
down unless you've had a very borderline
painfully cold shower for social reasons
at least for me personally it can almost
be a requirement one last quick note
before we move on to the next question
which shares some overlap with this one
I mentioned a moment ago that the
information surrounding going from hot
to cold such as combining ice baths with
the sauna or even just doing the sauna
and winter swimming combination has done
in Finland or elsewhere is lacking one
of the areas I'd like to see more
information on is actually safety
there's clearly a cultural history in
some places of going from a hot sauna
right into an icy lake but there is at
least one case study reported in the
literature of a heavy smoker having a
heart attack
possibly as a result of a plaque rupture
caused by a coronary artery spasm after
doing many many rounds of contrast
immersion over several hours I
personally then I sighs interspersed
with sauna youths work Reuben style and
found it to be very very enjoyable it
seems to help me sleep better and I
definitely felt like my mood was
significantly affected for even the next
24 hours
more so than either alone so I'm hopeful
we'll see some research come out that
proves the case report to be irrelevant
Association and somehow demonstrating
ultimate safety but in the meantime I'm
hesitant and a little cautious for the
broader audience listening now I will
make the same advice I made earlier
please please be careful what you
subject yourself to you especially if
you have a condition that might warrant
such caution if in doubt check with the
position before you take up and you pull
reproach habit okay on to our next
question rob flicker asks dr. Rhonda
Patrick can you explain your thoughts on
how regular hyperthermic conditioning
and hypothermic stress relate to muscle
hypertrophy and strength training first
for a listener since Rob is clearly in
the know let me define what hyperthermic
conditioning is hyperthermic
conditioning refers to deliberately
acclimating yourself to heat either
independent up or in conjunction with
exercise I typically refer to
hypothermic conditioning in the context
of using the sauna because this is where
most empirical evidence is but there are
other modalities of heat exposure
including hot baths steam showers and
hot yoga and they probably create a
quality similar type of heat stress that
approximates on use on some level
depending on the intensity there are a
couple of main mechanisms that
hyperthermic conditioning through using
the sauna may plausibly affect muscle
hypertrophy first is to the robust
activation of heat shock proteins I
mentioned earlier how heat shock
proteins play a role in preventing
neurodegenerative diseases such as
Alzheimer's disease by helping proteins
maintain their proper 3-dimensional
structure not only does this have a role
in preventing the aggregation of
proteins but it also plays a role in
muscle hypertrophy here's why muscle
hypertrophy is ultimately the Delta
between protein degradation and new
protein synthesis when we train for
muscle hypertrophy we often put a lot of
thought into how to increase muscle
protein synthesis but if we reduce
protein degradation which is an effect
heat shock proteins have we still are
increasing our net protein synthesis by
increasing the difference between the
amount of new synthesis of muscle
protein versus the amount of degradation
that is happening this type of effect
has been shown in rats where it was
shown that a 30-minute heat treatment at
a temperature of around 160 reads
Fahrenheit or 41 degrees Celsius given
every 48 hours over a seven day period
caused a sustained increase in heat
shock proteins during that time frame
big surprise but more importantly this
actually correlated with a whopping 30%
more muscle regrowth than the control
group during the seven days after
immobilization which is not bad right
putting aside heat shock proteins for a
moment the other way that hypothermic
conditioning through using the sauna
could plausibly affect hypertrophy is by
robustly increasing growth hormone for
example to 20 minutes on a sessions at
around 176 degrees Fahrenheit or 80
degrees Celsius separated by a 30-minute
cooling period elevated growth hormone
levels to fold over baseline
more robust effect was found with men
using higher sauna temperatures for
example two 15-minute sauna sessions at
around 212 degrees Fahrenheit which is
around 100 degrees Celsius separated by
a 30-minute cooling period resulted in a
five-fold increase in growth hormone the
boost in growth hormone levels is
transient only lasts a couple of hours
to understand why this might be useful
it's helpful to understand a little bit
more about this pathway many of the
effects of growth hormone are mediated
through another hormone known as igf-1
or insulin-like growth factor-1
igf-1 activating another pathway and
skeletal muscle known as mTOR which is
responsible for new protein synthesis
muscle cells require amino acids for
both growth and repair so if we can also
plausibly activate mTOR we're now sort
of completing the circle with heat shock
protein induction we reduce protein
degradation and through these endocrine
effects actually we are increasing
protein synthesis by increasing net
protein synthesis we effectively
increase hypertrophy in fact if you sort
of reverse engineer the habits of body
builders igf-1 is actually one of the
major pathways most robustly activated
by dietary protein intake so the next
time you're travelling down protein
powder or essential amino acids like
loosing you can be aware that part of
what you're doing in the first place is
robustly activating the production and
release of igf-1 and thus mTOR protein
and specifically essential amino acids
are the major dietary regulars of igf-1
igf-1 plays a very important role in
muscle growth and repair for example
mice that have been engineered to
express high levels of igf-1 in their
muscle develop a greater degree and
diversity of skeletal muscle hypertrophy
similar experiments have also shown some
promise in combating age-related muscle
atrophy especially the kind found in a
mouse model of Duchenne muscular
dystrophy I've previously talked a
little bit about a so called trade-off
when it comes to igf-1 I'm not going to
dive into that yet we'll talk a little
bit about that more in some of the diet
related questions but suffice to say I
think that in the context of sufficient
physical activity this so-called
trade-off may become a bit less
important that said let's take a minute
to talk about the timing of sauna use in
particular and then we can talk about
cold showers or ice baths I like to
sauna after a workout first there's
entirely practical reasons doing an
intense sauna session prior to working
out can increase exhaustion a little bit
too quickly making it very hard to
finish a workout
studies have shown that to be the case
empirically - but it's also intuitively
obvious and on top of that the social
aspect of potentially drenching gym
equipment and your profuse sweating
makes it a little more sensible to sauna
afterwards but if it were not for those
reasons in particular there's also just
the issue of when we most want to boost
igf-1 to answer that question it's
helpful to be aware of the mechanism
involved in hypertrophy one of which in
fact becomes especially relevant when we
talk about the effect cold stress has
after training in a moment that
mechanism is inflammation when we train
as a result of mechanical work being
done we produce metabolic byproducts
like reactive oxygen species and we also
activate inflammatory cytokines this is
actually necessary to activate genetic
pathways that contribute to creating
more mitochondria mitochondrial
biogenesis as we talked about earlier
and also plays a role in muscle
hypertrophy in fact it is inflammation
that recruits immune cells such as
macrophages to skeletal muscle in order
to produce igf-1 that helps induce acute
muscle repair there has also been some
experimental evidence that indicates
that these specific immune cells are
also likely involved in Satellite cell
migration which is a type of muscle stem
cell that serve as precursors to actual
muscle cells and for which the raw
numbers are actually very closely
associated with the amount of actual
hypertrophy that occurs as a result of
strength training as we can see
inflammation seems to play a pretty
important role in the benefits of actual
training and this inflammation as
measured by an inflammatory cytokine
known as il-6
actually peaks during training and also
right after but then falls by 50% of its
initial peak after the first hour so in
a way if you're going to try to pick a
time to increase growth hormone or igf-1
activity it makes sense to probably do
so in close proximity to when it's
actually peaking in my mind I interpret
this to be pretty much immediately on
the tail end of my workout this peak of
inflammation potentiating igf-1
synthesis that goes on to play a role
and hypertrophy may become especially
relevant if we talk about the mixed
research surrounding cold stress such as
ice baths or cryotherapy especially when
used in conjunction with working out
whereas the sauna seems to be just fine
and maybe even beneficial to do
immediately after exercise cold water
immersion and possibly other modalities
of cold exposure are a bit more nuanced
in the context of strength training
specifically studies have shown mixed
results when paired with strength
training for example one
2015 setting the Journal of physiology
showed that a 10-minute Coldwater
immersion immediately falling heavy leg
training dramatically decreased
hypertrophy by almost two-thirds a
10-week follow-up the active coal
treatment group also had a reduction in
muscle strength and showed smaller
increases in type 2 muscle fibers which
are required for very short duration
high intensity bursts of power and all
of this coincided with a reduction in
biomarkers that are usually associated
with hypertrophy including the
activation of satellite cells
that's pretty alarming if you think
about it but maybe it shouldn't be too
surprising let's unpack this anti
hypertrophy effect of cold a little bit
one of the reasons ice baths became
popular in professional sports for
example is because cold exposure blunts
inflammation and specifically it's been
shown to dramatically decrease the
production of what are known as the e2
series prostaglandins which are one of
the factors that have specifically been
shown to induce the synthesis of igf-1
by macrophages that growth factor
mentioned earlier because it's important
for hypertrophy in addition to this cold
exposure also causes vasoconstriction
which may acutely prevent immune cells
from migrating to places like muscle
tissue knowing how to produce
inflammation when needed is good but
only if we account for the various
downstream effects that this may have
this is not the only study although it's
the best one that has shown that
Coldwater immersion done immediately
after strength training may blunt some
hypertrophy there are others but again
all of those studies use cold exposure
sometime immediately after strength
training so that leaves us with a few
open questions but the most important
one is this would we still have seen the
blunted or reduced hypertrophy effects
if cold water immersion was done at
literally any point other than
immediately after strength training I
don't think that based on the current
literature we can state this with a
hundred percent certainty at this stage
but if we take into the account this
potentially inflammatory mediated
anabolic window that seems to peak
especially in the first hour post
exercise that it might help to explain
some of the mixed results we see
surrounding the use of cold stress with
various forms of strength training
specifically one 2013 study from the
Scandinavian Journal of Medicine and
science sports showed the exact opposite
effect this study showed that whole body
cryotherapy for a couple of minutes down
one hour after squat Johnson leg curls
was actually associated with performance
enhancements which included improvements
in power at the start of the squat jump
and
jump workout and improved pain measures
up to 72 hours after the cold treatment
this isn't the only study showing an
enhancement performance from cold either
we see an it study published in PLoS ONE
in 2011 that elite runners that engaged
in whole body cryotherapy one hour 24
hours or 48 hours after doing some Hill
sprinting ultimately had a 20% increase
in speed and power up to two days later
what's interesting about the cold is
that it may also be conducive to
enhancing endurance related activities
in particular like fad whereby cold can
increase the number of mitochondria and
white adipose tissue in order to trans
differentiate into brown fat a form of
fat that is metabolically active
protective against obesity and naturally
declines with age muscle also
experiences an increase in mitochondria
as a consequence of cold exposure these
mitochondria are the energy producing
machinery of our muscle cells the
density or number of them on a per cell
basis affects our aerobic capacity
mitochondria are what give us the
ability to use oxygen in order to
produce cellular energy and if we have
more of them it can be said we may be
more adapted to aerobic activity okay
all of that said to sort of get to the
point to summarize my thoughts on sauna
and cold water immersion or cryotherapy
in the context of exercise I think that
sauna use after exercise seems to be a
good time to do it generally speaking we
need more research but cryotherapy or
cold water immersion may be better to
hold out on until at least an hour after
training and finally the effects of and
the appropriateness of cold related
activities on performance may for a few
different reasons be very dependent on
the actual activity we're actively
training for alright on to the next
question
Kevin Noonan thick asks what are your
thoughts on nootropic cognitive
enhancing supplements and do you take
any yourself
for example choline lion's mane mushroom
etc I do take some things that might
qualify as nootropics I am however very
conscious in what I choose to experiment
with at least over the long term my
biggest concern comes down to one simple
fact when we introduce outside compounds
that to directly perturb complex
biological systems we opened up the
possibility of triggering feedback
systems that can then result in
unintended consequences such as receptor
down regulation what do I mean by that
for example let's say we take a
pharmacological drug that inhibits
transporters that reuptake and
metabolized neurotransmitters
causes these neurotransmitters to then
stay around the synapse for a longer
period of time exerting more biological
effects this might be perceived as a
good thing
but the trade-off is that this cause of
the receptors that bind this various
neurotransmitters which is how they
actually exert their biological effect
to decrease in number this is what we
call down regulation so what happens
when you do not take that same drug for
a few days your baseline level has
changed so that in the absence of those
drugs that inhibit reuptake your
neurotransmitters will not by themselves
exert the same effect that they might
have had before your pharmacological
intervention due to the changes in
receptor density or the number of
receptors we have for the
neurotransmitter to interact with this
is one reason why I prefer to instead
focus primarily in the realm of
nutrition since it usually works a
little bit more indirectly by providing
compounds that are found in and needed
by the body and in the context of this
conversation the brain additionally when
compounds are identified in food such as
Zeno hormetic compounds we have a better
chance of achieving benefit without
deleterious effects because the fact
that we've likely evolved alongside the
presence of that compound if the
compound or compounds don't have that
same history it takes a little bit more
scrutiny before we can be sure that
there isn't some sort of significant
side effects we just haven't taken the
time to observe yet maybe we won't even
know about it for years for this reason
I tend to stay away from compounds that
are inhibitors of enzymes in the brain
which I know are ubiquitously found in
many nootropic stacks even though they
likely work in a short-term we don't
have any good evidence of what if any
long-term effects that may occur with
that said there are some nootropics that
I have tried choline is one of them :
can be either used to make acetylcholine
acetylcholine is a neurotransmitter that
connects neurons together or faust
chattel choline or methyl groups in
humans choline supplements increased
choline plasma levels within one hour
after ingestion and with brain
concentrations peaking around two hours
until at least up to three hours after
ingestion choline effects on the
cholinergic peripheral system Peaks
between 1 and 2 hours after ingestion
cooling itself without forming
acetylcholine
acts on a subtype of nicotinic receptors
called alpha 7 nicotinic receptor that
is involved in long-term memory
acetylcholine also acts on all the
nicotinic receptors : does not cause
desensitization of this receptor like
other agonists do like nicotine for
example in
act supplementing with : increases this
receptor subtypes certain
neurodegenerative disorders like
Alzheimer's disease are linked to
decrease conceale choline so there has
been a lot of interest in investigating
whether certain choline supplements and
other compounds that affect the
cholinergic system can improve cognition
of memory and people with cognitive
decline and dementia and Alzheimer's
disease for example there are different
forms of choline supplements but I think
the : that is complex to phosphatidyl
choline is the best because it is 12
times more bioavailable and gets into
the brain faster there's a decent body
of evidence that has looked at the
effects of various types of cooling and
brain function l alpha glycerol
phosphoryl choline were commonly known
as alpha GPC is a naturally occurring
form of choline and is thought to be a
form of colon that crosses the
blood-brain barrier quickly I came
across this compound when doing a
literature review of various
phospholipids and their role in
Alzheimer's disease the study that put
this on the map was an old study
published in 2003 that demonstrated
1,200 milligrams a day split up over 3
daily doses was able to enhance
cognitive performance and slow cognitive
decline in Alzheimer's patients the
problem is this study was done in Mexico
City 13 years ago since then another
study in 2011 attempted to repeat this
but in addition to alpha GPC about 10
other compounds were given it improved
cognitive function but it's impossible
to pinpoint this effect specifically to
alpha GPC finally there is yet another
interesting study that showed that alpha
GPC along with other natural compounds
reduce reaction times and prevented
mental exhaustion after intense exercise
an effect that is likely due to the
replenishment of choline that is
actually temporarily reduced in the
brain as a consequence of endurance
exercise such as long runs
I have personally tried alpha GPC before
at a dose of around 600 milligrams a day
an amount that is half the dose that was
given to the demented patients in Mexico
City and I noticed that it did seem to
improve my focus and attention you
should always leave a little room for a
possibility that there may be a placebo
effect but since it's my anecdote a
smaller dose of 300 milligrams didn't
really seem to have much of an effect on
me
in general I do not take alpha GPC every
day I take it on rare occasions when I'm
doing a lot of writing or if there's
some sort of event that I'm speaking at
there is another popular form of choline
called CDP choline which is an
intermediate produce during the
generation of phosphatidylcholine from
choline there are a couple of human
studies
looking at the effects of CDP choline in
cognitive function of healthy young or
middle-aged adults usually in the range
of around thousand milligrams a day the
only benefits were seen in young adults
that had poor processing speed and
verbal memory test at baseline strangely
those individuals that performed well at
baseline actually had impaired
performance after supplementation which
may have to do with genetic variants in
the receptor density or something which
just sort of goes to show you how
complicated neurobiology is and how even
seemingly straightforward relationships
can turn out to be not so
straightforward
I have personally tried CDP coaling and
never really notice any enhancing effect
like I seem to with alpha GPC the other
nootropic that I have tried a new semi
frequently is Yamaguchi taka extract
which is also more commonly known as
lion's mane the main active compound in
lion's mane is harissa nones which is
found in the fruit body of the mushroom
this compound is capable of activating
nerve growth factor nerve growth factor
is essential for the growth of new
neurons and survival of existing neurons
nerve growth factor acts on the
cholinergic neurons in the central
nervous system what got me interested in
lion's mane as a nootropic was a
Japanese study which was a
double-blinded placebo-controlled trial
where elderly men were with cognitive
decline were given one gram doses of 96%
Yamaguchi taka dried powder three times
a day for 16 weeks for a total of 3
grams a day those individuals given the
Lions Mane's extract but not Lucy Bo had
a significant improvement in cognitive
function at weeks 8 12 and 16 of the
trial but the cognitive effects were off
for weeks after discontinuing the
treatment suggesting that a continuous
intake was necessary to maintain the
effect at least in cognitively impaired
older adults lately I do use lion's mane
extract pretty regularly from 4 sig
Matic they come in packets and each
packet contains around 1.5 grams of
lion's mane extract from the fruit body
only which would contain harissa notes I
have no affiliation with them they send
me some free packets a couple of years
ago and I liked them so I continued to
buy them when I use them which only
again happens to be during periods of
intense writing or creative work I
actually use two packets a dose that is
around 3 grams of lion's mane extract
and the same dose used in the clinical
study I mentioned a moment ago out of
Japan no discussion of new topics would
be complete if I didn't at least briefly
mention to hobby horses of mine vitamin
D and omega-3 these
BECs of both of these are pretty
far-reaching and extend far far beyond
the realms of just cognition but even if
one were only concerned with just
cognition they would still both have
special relevance first let's talk
vitamin D this one is near and dear to
my heart since it was my in silikal work
that actually identified that vitamin D
affects serotonin production which I
believe has very far far-reaching
implications not just for adults trying
to stay healthy and live optimally but
also for neurodevelopmental disorders as
well where impaired serotonin production
may be particularly important for early
brain development when the fetus relies
on the mother as its source for vitamin
D a whopping nearly seventy percent of
people in United States can be
classified as vitamin D insufficient and
that includes pregnant women ok
returning to the main topic after that
brief digression vitamin D is something
that should be periodically monitored by
a blood test in order to titrate to a
dose as appropriate
I personally shoot for forty to sixty
nanograms four milliliters since there
have been a few all cause mortality
studies that seem to indicate that this
may be a so-called sweet spot because
vitamin D can be toxic in the high upper
ranges doing too much can also be
problematic it's an absolute fact that
what may work for one person especially
in terms of dose may not for another
because of the individual variation
involved and can affect how deficient
you are including genetic polymorphisms
wait age the latitude at which you live
ethnicity how much time you spend
outdoors whether or not you wear
sunscreen and so many other things I
personally found that the tolerable
upper intake level recommended by the
Institute of Medicine of just four
thousand I use usually taken with a
vitamin k2 supplement is actually the
amount that lands me right in the middle
of that target range that said I'm
probably not even in the highest risk
category for vitamin D deficiency next a
quick mention for omega-3 approximately
8% of the brain's weight is actually
omega-3 the number of studies that
demonstrate optimizing intake of omega-3
has some effect on cognition or behavior
are extremely diverse today we've talked
a little bit about nerve growth factors
so just by way of example I literally
ran across an animal study that showed
that supplemental omega-3 increases
nerve growth factor which increases the
enzyme responsible for producing a co
choline it also increases vascular
endothelial growth factor and
brain-derived neurotropic factor and has
generally been shown to improve
cognition but I'll talk a little bit
more about this in an
another question getting past all the
usual suspects on our list of nootropics
here the other nootropic that I actually
take frequently is sulforaphane it's not
even usually considered a nootropic by
most people but I think it has potential
to be considered at least a mild
nootropics for a variety of reasons one
of the best reasons to make this
argument is the fact that sulfur refrain
crosses the blood-brain barrier at least
in mice this is the first criteria that
a substance must meet in order for there
to be a compelling argument that it's
somehow exerts effects on the brain but
in addition to that it also affects the
activities of the immune system which is
now known to affect the brain through a
series of lymphatic vessels this new
understanding of the immune system's
ability to interact with the brain also
helps to explain why manipulating levels
of systemic inflammation has in clinical
trials been shown to affect feelings of
depression either inducing depression in
the presence of an artificial increase
in activity in the immune system by
injecting things like interference into
human trial participants or reducing
depression caused by this artificial
increase in inflammation through the ko
administration of natural
anti-inflammatories such as like OSA
pentanoic acid better known as the
omega-3 fatty acid EPA in addition to
sulfur in crossing the blood-brain
barrier in mice the compound has been
shown in a couple of randomized
double-blinded placebo-controlled
studies in humans to have one sort of
effect or another on brain and behavior
for example treatment with sulfur fin
extracted from broccoli sprouts at doses
ranging from around 9 milligrams to 25
milligrams which is an amount that might
be found in around 65 grams of fresh
broccoli sprouts on the high end was
able to improve autistic behavior
checklist scores by 34% and
significantly improved social
interaction abnormal behavior and verbal
communication in young men with autism
spectrum disorder similarly some
measurable effects have been shown in a
small trial of people with schizophrenia
the fact that sulforaphane is exhibiting
clear effects on the brain and behavior
of people such as those with autism
spectrum disorder he said it might
continue to show promise in other areas
of cognition - this is because animal
studies have really shown a diversity of
very interesting effects on the brain
that are really just waiting to be
replicated in humans for example so fur
grant has been shown to improve spatial
working memory and short-term memory in
mice in the context of conditions that
can affect memory in a deleterious way
such as Alzheimer's disease it has been
shown to increase in a row outgrow
which is how damaged neurons and
synapses repair themselves after damage
from traumatic brain injury The effect
of sulfur and on a rodent model of
Alzheimer's disease in some respects is
particularly interesting because if we
go back to our conversation a little bit
earlier about the potential calling they
have for mitigating some of the negative
effects of this disorder so fur frame
has also been shown to significantly
reduce memory impairment that has been
experimentally induced by a drug that
works specifically by interfering with
the effects of acetylcholine in the
nervous system
a drug known as scopolamine sulfur
Korean was in this animal trials which
I'm referring to able to improve the
cholinergic system by increasing
acetylcholine levels decreasing
acetylcholine esterase activity and
increasing colon acetyl transferase
which is the enzyme responsible for
synthesizing seal choline in the
hippocampus and frontal cortex this ties
in nicely with some of our discussion
earlier about the potential importance
of choline system in cognition finally
sulfur frame has been shown to have a
positive effect on mood and alleviated
depressive symptoms and anxiety as
effectively as the an depressant Prozac
in a mouse model of depression and I
understand that there is at least one
trial currently in the beginning stages
looking to confirm this effect in humans
as well if you consider that the variety
of brain and other behavioral effects
demonstrated already in humans I'm
optimistically hoping that some of the
groups out there working on these
questions will have something good to
show for it in the near future if you're
looking to supplemental for a frame as a
few options available first of all the
most confusing thing that is necessary
to understand when gauging the various
supplements for usefulness is that
sulfur frame is made from a precursor
known as quickl rafen in many
supplements on the market are actually
just squiggle raffinate you know this
because it either says glucoraphanin on
the bottle or it says so fer a flanger
Kaasen aid which is actually somewhat
confusingly just another name for google
rocman then there are a few supplements
on the market that is glucoraphanin and
the enzyme needed to convert it into
sulfur freeing an enzyme called
myrosinase one example of this
combination is a product known as AB
McCall finally there's an actual
stabilizer for a frame this includes a
French product that hasn't been
introduced the u.s. yet known as
processing these three categories of
products that I've mentioned have very
very large differences in terms of
bioavailability around 10% on average
for google rafen and by itself 40% for
the glue carafe and and and
Rossini's combination and then around
70% to stabilize sulforaphane
by the way I have no affiliation with
any of those supplement brands I just
mentioned the dosage rain that strikes
me is particularly interesting because
they have shown up often in clinical
trials range between 30 to 60 milligrams
of sulfur in a day these doses however
actually make most of the supplements
out there somewhat costly in my opinion
the good news is that many studies seem
to be showing promise even at a lower
dose and if you're doing an end of one
experiment it may be useful to be able
to get a reliable product like the ones
I just mentioned that said this cost
factor has been a big reason for why
I've simply taken up growing broccoli
sprouts at home which is extremely
inexpensive the main challenge being
keeping a clean environment with little
possibility of contamination from
pathogenic bacteria which can definitely
happen
some estimates land fresh broccoli
sprouts at a concentration of about 1
gram fresh weight to about 0.45
milligrams of sulfur frame but it
depends on seed quality and genetic
background the age of the sprouts how
you consume the sprouts whether you
froze them and threw them immediately
into a blender which is what I tend to
do intends to increase the amount of
sulfur a frame derived or if you instead
just chew them up the good old-fashioned
way the drawback to using sprouts is
that dosing them becomes tricky the fact
of the matter is is that I found my own
personal digestion is probably a more
reliable source of feedback than trying
to work out the dosage math that's kind
of embarrassing ly imprecise I have to
admit but it just comes down to the fact
that there's a tremendous number of
variables that can influence how much
sulforaphane in a given dose of broccoli
sprouts and on top of that what an
appropriate amount of sulfur referring
to even supplement is I have been known
to consume up to four ounces of broccoli
sprouts a few times a week and I will
likely continue for the foreseeable
future that said there are concerns that
Isis IO signings like sulfur refrain may
reduce iodine uptake by the thyroid
gland while right now I don't think the
evidence is especially strong that this
is cause for great concern unless a
person is iodine deficient which is an
uncommon deficiency it may be prudent to
exercise some degree of caution some of
the effects of these compounds present
in cruciferous vegetables and broccoli
sprouts in particular are persistent for
several days so you don't necessarily
need to take an extreme approach in
order to reap some benefit again run it
by your doctor etc etc okay on to the
next question which is somewhat related
jazz theory
is one able to cold-pressed use broccoli
sprouts and still receive high amounts
of sulfur refrain from ingesting it this
way to answer your question yes you
should be able to call press broccoli
sprouts and make a juice the myrosinase
enzyme which again is needed to activate
sulfur vein begins to get activated once
you cold press the sprouts because by
cold pressing you are breaking open
plant cell walls and causing the mixing
of glucoraphanin in the plant with the
myrosinase enzyme which is stored away
and specialized vacuoles this mixing
then allow suffering to form ultimately
you would not be getting the same
dietary fiber which is why I prefer to
blend things rather than juice them but
the sulfur frame would be concentrated
and since it may be less aversive it
seems like an interesting option next
question is from William McGrath besides
a low-carb diet which reduces
inflammation what is the most effective
non-pharmaceutical pain reliever for
arthritis sport injury sufferers ok
Williams question here is an interesting
one the reason for that is because of
the fact that many NSAIDs as in
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
which are often used for mild pain
relief are actually not especially safe
to take on a daily basis this is even
more true of people that tend to take
them in larger than reccommend doses and
is why the FDA recently strengthened
their warning that non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs again known as
NSAIDs with the exception to aspirin
significantly increase the risk of heart
attack or stroke even with short-term
use with these NSAIDs including
ibuprofen that causes increased risk
have in common is that they all inhibit
cox-2 an enzyme involved in inflammation
and pain there are a few fundamental
mechanisms that increase the risk of
heart attack and stroke first NSAIDs
that inhibit cox-2 inhibit the
production of a molecule called
prostacyclin
which is produced by Cox 2 and relaxes
blood vessels and sort of unglued
platelets second they inhibit the
production of nitric oxide which is also
regulated by clocks 2 to some degree and
needed for proper vascular function
finally one more mechanism by which
chronic NSAIDs may increase heart attack
risk is through the disruption of
mitochondrial function in heart cells
knowing these risks sort of motivated me
to put avoiding the use of NSAIDs such
as ibuprofen Aleve and naproxen just to
name a few at a generally a higher
priority than it may have been
previously for me on
level as an alternative to the use of
NSAIDs however I found that curcumin is
actually very helpful curcumin is sort
of an interesting compound it exhibits a
pretty diverse array of potentially
beneficial properties but as a
xenobiotic that the body actively makes
an effort to get rid of its activity
could be limited unless care is taken to
try to make it more bioavailable there's
a few different formulations that
attempt to do that but the one that I
found most interesting is a formulation
known as Mareva which has been shown to
exhibit certain pain relieving
properties Meriva a form which is
available from a few well-known brand
consists of a phospholipid complex with
20% curcumin dispersed throughout the
phospholipid this helps to get the
curcumin tasks of stomach lining and
from being cleared by enzymes in the
liver to rapidly a few clinical trials
have looked into the effects of Moorea
on pain and inflammation for example
runners that were given one gram of
remover twice a day found that reduced
delayed onset muscle soreness by about
twofold and caused a 60% decrease in
markers of muscle damage and
inflammation specifically aisle eight
and c-reactive protein after running
until exhaustion downhill there have
also been a couple of other clinical
studies published looking at the
efficacy of one gram of Maria bad day in
reducing symptoms of osteoarthritis and
increasing mobility after three months
of treatment people with osteoarthritis
and joint pain had a four-fold increase
in mobility c-reactive protein decreased
by 67 percent and they had a rounded 58
percent reduction arthritis symptoms
including pain there was a similar study
that included a longer follow-up which
was eight months and found similar
increases in mobility and reductions in
inflammation and pain what's interesting
is that Mareva has also been compared
directly to common pain relievers in
terms of ability to give pain relief in
a small clinical study which found that
people taking two grams of Moorea a day
experienced the pain relief equivalent
to one gram of acetaminophen or Tylenol
an amount by the way which has been
associated with liver damage in
conjunction with long-term use another
study also found that 2 grams a day of
Mareva for six weeks with equivalent to
around 800 milligrams a day of ibuprofen
for pain relief the study found that the
analgesic effect of curcumin lasted for
approximately four hours and a second
dose administered around 6 to 12 hours
after the first dose was necessary for
controlling pain on the whole curcumin
is a also a surprisingly safe compound
one study out of Japan published in 2011
the Journal of cancer chemotherapy and
pharmacology showed that curcumin into
the mounts as high as even eight grams
per day for up to 14 days at a time
with safe and tolerable these were
cancer patients and this wasn't a Mareva
formulation however seeing how well
tolerated very high clinical doses are
generally for occasional pain relief I
tend to be pretty liberal with topping a
few grams of curcumin in the form of
Arriva throughout the day there's a few
popular brands offering Mareva or
sometimes simply marketed as by the
Zilla curcumin right now the one I'm
taking is the product from thorne again
like every other supplement brand I've
ever mentioned on this podcast no
affiliation whatsoever since I sort of
pork or cumin and Maria out there
specifically as a knife and sait
alternative I'd need to address the
grill on the room quite recently a very
sensational scientific review was making
the rounds claiming that curcumin
basically had no health benefits and
that because of a quirk of an
investigative method used to look at
protein protein interactions that may be
subject to some degree of imprecision
because of how it can behave in a manner
that produces background noise all
curcumin research up until this point
should be more or less considered null
and void that was sort of the crux of
the argument and a handful of
unsuccessful trials were also cited to
support in my opinion poorly this
argument the problem is that the
specific quirk of the research assay
being discussed is rendered absolutely
and completely irrelevant in the context
of the massive body of clinical curcumin
research done in humans that has shown
the compound is exceedingly versatile
moreover even if we put aside the
enormous amount of clinical research
it's been demonstrated that curcumin
works in a manner that at the cellular
level exhibits broad changes in gene
expression something that cannot be
dismissed simply because one specific
assay which by the way does not even
measure gene expression exhibit some
degree of artifact if you couldn't tell
I'm not a big fan this particular review
article published and may even feel a
little bit of desire to sort of heat
mountains of admonishment on the authors
that said I will concede that there is a
need for more double-blinded
placebo-controlled studies on curcumin
and specifically the Meriva vitae soma
complex of curcumin which does
significantly bypass the bioavailability
issues associated with the compound
which is also been the source of some
criticism I am however very very
optimistic about
to research surrounding curcumin in
general and Mareva in particular finally
one more thing I should bring up in the
context of joint health is hydrolyzed
collagen powder what first sparked my
interest in this was a study shared with
me by a colleague that established the
fact that at least in an animal model
hydrolyzed collagen supplemented in the
diet did find its way into the cartilage
sometimes the nutrition relationships
don't tend to be so straightforward as
it may seem intuitive on the surface
cholesterol is a great example of this
we actually create cholesterol and the
consumption of dietary cholesterol is
not necessarily strictly a cause of high
cholesterol as we think of it in the
case of hydrolyzed collagen powder
however the relationship does seem to be
straightforward the study to which I'm
referring to used radio labeled collagen
which allowed the scientists that were
doing the investigation to see what
happened after the hydrolyzed collagen
was consumed they saw two things
happened that the collagen ended up
being broken down into amino acids but
more importantly that some of it was
also absorbed intact and shown to
accumulate in cartilage long-term which
is pretty cool so a little bit about
collagen collagen is an important
component of tendons ligaments cartilage
and skin but also an important component
of gums muscle and the gut about 33% of
collagen is made from prolene and
glycine which most dietary protein
sources are not especially high in
prolene may also have a special place in
wound healing as well the first ten days
after a wound occurs prolene levels at
the site of the wound are 50% higher
than plasma which might suggest that
prolene is actively being transported to
the site of the wound and probably a
necessary part of the wound healing
process as an interesting aside polling
can also be used by the mitochondria to
produce energy is converted to glutamate
and alpha ketoglutarate and used by
mitochondria to produce energy
the reason this pathway exists is
because during conditions when glucose
levels drop prolene is actually released
from connective tissue to be used to
make energy I've heard Tim mentioned
great lakes brand hydrolyzed collagen
powder which happens to be the same
brand that I've used for the last few
years it does not have any particularly
strong taste so it can pretty much be
added to anything including a beverage
like tea or coffee or pretty much
anything else ok next question guys a
Siana asks what brands can we trust for
dietary supplement brands how can we
find trustworthy brands this is a great
question and an important question
because the FDA
not require dietary supplements to be
tested before they are marketed as a
result products may contain unlisted
ingredients and contaminants some
products have even tested positive for
prescription drugs not listed on the
label many supplements do not contain
what they're actually supposed to
contain and instead may be a combination
of fillers like cloverleaf
so there's a few things you can do one
thing you can do is make sure the
product is certified by NSF
international which stands for the
National sanitary foundation which
independently tests and certifies
dietary supplements and nutritional
products ensures that they do not
contain undeclared ingredients or
contaminants to earn NSF dietary
supplement certification products must
undergo rigorous testing and inspection
the standard requires label claim
testing verification and contaminant
review and a facility audit you can look
for products containing the NSF label by
searching their dietary supplements
online product database found at info
NSS org slash certified / dietary I
usually will just type in the
manufacturer name for example Nordic
Naturals or I will type in a specific
product that I'm looking for like Meriva
the drawback to relying on this
particular certification is that their
database can be pretty restrictive while
being in the NSF database is a good sign
not being in it strictly is not a
deal-breaker so here's another option
look for products that are USP certified
the USP which stands for the United
States form a copula convention is a
scientific nonprofit organization that
sets standards for the quality and
purity of dietary supplements that are
manufactured distributed and consumed
worldwide in the United States the FBI
relies on standards the USB has
developed you can just go to their
website which is a USP org and click
verified supplements to see a list of
brands and products within brands that
the USP verifies in addition to the USP
and NSF there are independent companies
that also test supplements and then rank
those products and provide reports to
customers sometimes for a cost however I
found these to be either misleading or
sometimes coming to conclusions that
give me pause doing the type of
validation necessary may require
technical skills that might be executed
poorly or sometimes just plain weird
ranking criteria may be at play for that
reason I don't trust these independent
ranking companies as much but apps and
other information it may still be better
than just blindly grabbing something off
of super
market shelf onto the next question
James and Wright asks Rhonda what are
your core supplements in core foods for
health or brain and daily weekly health
routine okay first my perspective on
food I think it's helpful to understand
what I'm about to say because it to a
great degree informs other opinions I
may have about different approaches on
diet food is in a big way a vehicle to
deliver micronutrients or compounds that
are beneficial to health but not just
micronutrients other compounds such as
polyphenols and others you know hormetic
compounds as well approximately 22% of
all the genes that encode for enzymes
require micronutrients as cofactors
which means that the machinery doing
work inside yourself actually needs
micronutrients to function properly
these are enzymes that are involved in
metabolism neurotransmitter production
repairing damage basically everything
that you want to be working optimally
needs more than just energy it needs
micro nutrients it needs minerals like
magnesium which we find particularly
abundant in green leafy vegetables
because it's at the center of a
chlorophyll molecule micronutrients are
about 30 to 40 essential vitamins
minerals fatty acids and amino acids
that we must get from our diet because
they are essential for life that means
without them you die recommended daily
intakes of these vitamins and minerals
have been set to ensure we get adequate
amounts of them but we really do not
know how much of these micronutrients we
need to stave off aging as best we can
if the proteins in your body start
operating more poorly let's say they
stop repairing DNA damage quite as well
or they aren't cleaning up amyloid beta
as well or any of the almost infinite
number of other potentially affected
processes you might not notice this as a
disease instead we might just call it
aging it's important therefore to keep
in mind that preventing aging is not the
goal of the RDA it is to prevent easily
observable obvious diseases of
deficiency and figuring out what those
optimal levels are for this more subtile
and widespread thing we call aging is a
bit more challenging adding some
complication to this is the fact that
this optimal level is probably not the
same for everyone perhaps as a function
of the agricultural practices or
constraints placed by foods dictated
partly by the geographic area our
ancestors resided in there's a great
degree of genetic influence and how much
we absorb metabolize and use
micronutrients understanding just some
of these interactions between genetic
polymorphisms in food is an area
a city known as nutrigenomics it is
fascinated Lee complex and there's a
great deal of opportunity for
understandings in this area to improve
the human condition as an extension of
this fact I think the specifics of diet
will eventually be better understood to
not be a one size fits all that said I
found some things that have worked for
me personally and some of them are
probably still relatively generalizable
in love as to be useful for others here
they are I know most people are focused
on macronutrients that makes sense in
certain contexts so long as it isn't the
complete and utter exclusion of all else
instead
I just mainly follow a rule of thumb
that I should eliminate refined
carbohydrates in particular and refined
sugar especially and then I try to eat
with a special attention to nutrient
density I often enjoy wedging and
smoothie and sometimes as a partial meal
substitute that it's particularly
focused on cramming and some extra
servings of some fruits and vegetables I
consider this to be a pretty important
lifestyle hack that can sort of just be
thrown on top of whatever else you're
doing and it will help recalibrate a lot
of important health parameters in a very
useful way as for actual meals I always
eat breakfast and as mentioned earlier I
practiced I'm restricted eating's that
all of my meals are consumed earlier in
the day and within a sensible time
window while some degree of diversity is
ideal for breakfast I often do rotate
between a few reliable meals first when
the main meals that I eat for breakfast
are scrambled eggs usually topped with
tomatillo salsa which helps make the
eggs less boring sauteed kale and garlic
topped with olive oil salt and mustard
powder and a grapefruit on the side I
scrambled my eggs and sauteed my kale
and avocado oil because it is high in
monounsaturated fat and low in
polyunsaturated fat I tend to stay away
from cooking oils that are high in
polyunsaturated fat because it's so
easily oxidized it can be very harmful
consuming oxidized fat the avocado oil
also has a very high smoke point so it
can withstand some heat the reason why i
saute the kale is very practical it's
easier to eat I add mustard powder to
the kale as well as other cruciferous
vegetables but it may cook with other
meals to facilitate the conversion of
precursors into isothiocyanates like the
sulfur refrain from broccoli one of the
main reasons I eat eggs is that eggs
provide me with choline we already
talked about how cooling affects the
acetylcholine levels but it also serves
as a methylation source and thus affects
global epigenetics which is a way of
changing the activation or deactivation
of various genes
when extremely common genetic
polymorphism is in a gene that encodes
for an enzyme that catalyzes the
synthesis of phosphate or coaling and
mescaline postmenopausal women in
particular with this polymorphism need
to increase their dietary intake of
choline eggs happen to be a great source
of choline I spread some tomatillo sauce
on top of my eggs because I like it for
most but it helps that's also high in
tomato diene which has been shown to
boost muscle mass in mice by reducing
the activity of a gene called a TF for
known for inhibiting muscle protein
synthesis in addition to the sulfur
refrain and micronutrients another
reason why I like kale law is because it
is one of the vegetables that is highest
in lutein and zeaxanthin - carotenoids
that most people associate with eye
health because they accumulate in the
rods and cones of the eye and protect
them from singlet oxygen which is
generated from blue light and can be
very damaging to the eye but recently
there have been a fair amount of studies
published showing that these carotenoids
accumulate in large quantities in the
brain I mean what are they doing in the
brain there is no singlet oxygen from
light exposure in the brain plasma and
brain levels of lutein turned out to be
associated with a higher volume of gray
matter in the brain and improved
crystallized intelligence in the elderly
which is the ability to use the skills
and knowledge that one has acquired over
a lifetime a double blinded randomized
control trial showed that lutein and
zeaxanthin supplementation including
eight milligrams of lutein and 26
milligrams of the is anthon improved
neural processing speed time in young
individuals decreased processing speed
is a major hallmark of cognitive decline
lutein and zeaxanthin have been shown to
improve memory recall while using less
brain power in older individuals
something that's known as neural
efficiency an aging brain has to use
more and more energy to maintain normal
brain functions and so neural efficiency
is said to decline the icing on the cake
is that eating eggs with the salad
increases the absorption of carotenoids
like lutein and zeaxanthin which are
found in dark green leafy vegetables
particularly in kale by up to fourfold
which is one reason why I like to have a
side of eggs with my kale the grapefruit
provides me with furu lacasa a potent
molecule inhibits a pro-inflammatory
cytokine tina's alpha and e2 series
prostaglandins also inflammatory
freulich acid has also been shown to be
anti-carcinogenic the
grapefruit is also a source of noir
engine which has a variety of very
interesting properties another breakfast
that I haves and not in very cereal with
hydrolyzed collagen powder and coconut
milk my cereal also contains array of
chopped nuts including walnuts pecans
and macadamia nuts the Nets provided me
with a host of micro nutrients including
magnesium calcium zinc and a modest
amount of protein and the omega-3 fatty
acid ala which is not meant to be a
substitute for the marine omega-3s along
with the nuts I often toss in some
blueberries for taro sylveon which is a
plant compound present in blueberries
that is chemically related to
resveratrol except it's about four times
more bioavailable than resveratrol test
tube and rodent studies also suggest
that pterostilbene is more potent than
resveratrol when it comes to improving
brain function warding off various types
of cancer and preventing heart disease
the blueberries are also very high in
antecedents which evidence suggests can
lower DNA damage DNA damage has been
shown to cause cancer and lead to
depletion and stem field polls so it
also plays a important role in the aging
process as well I also like to add some
pomegranate into the cereal one of the
compounds in pomegranate is transformed
by gut microbes into a molecule called
Yura with an A which causes my tofu G a
process important for the renewal of
mitochondria I mentioned in an earlier
question your listen a has shown some
pretty spectacular things in research on
other organisms including improving
muscle function and endurance by up to
42 percent in mice and increasing
lifespan by more than 45 percent in
worms finally as the finishing touch the
breakfast cereal I often throw in some
flax seeds for more of the omega-3 ala
and fiber some unsweetened coconut milk
which contains some medium chain
triglycerides some raw cacao nibs which
have a plethora of polyphenols including
EGCG which activate many antioxidant
genes and have been shown to kill cancer
cells occasionally some almond butter
for some protein and sort of to make it
delicious
hydrolyzed collagen powder which
provides me with prolene as I mentioned
earlier is important for wound healing
and also has glycine which is an
important inhibitory neurotransmitter
one reason I use coconut milk as opposed
to regular milk or dairy milk is because
dairy milk contains Salaberry proteins
which bind to antigens and polyphenols
and limits their bioavailability
sometimes I'll also throw in the cereal
concoction some yogurt and possibly a
packet of the probiotic VSL number three
which contains 450
billion probiotic cells per serving okay
let's talk lunch this is where the
smoothie often comes in as a base it can
often contain kala frozen berries and
avocado hydrolyzed collagen powder and
water then a number of variations on top
of these I have a couple of popular
smoothie recipes that are floating
around on the Internet and a person can
find them by searching Rhonda Patrick's
smoothie as a breakfast or lunch I
occasionally have an avocado tops with
fresh lemon juice in wild alaskan salmon
roe possibly accompanied by a side of
sauerkraut this is another variation I
sometimes do avocados are really high in
potassium and provide all the various
forms of vitamin E in other words both
tocopherols and tocotrienols something
is good to get a balance of via diet
instead of only one form as from sub
supplements the Alba kado is also a
great source of monounsaturated fat
salmon roe caviar is a very good source
of omega-3 fatty acids approximately 438
milligrams of EPA and 514 milligrams of
DHA per ounce I particularly like the
source of omega-3 because the fats are
in phospholipid form which has greater
bioavailability to be transported into
the brain via the MF s d2 a transporter
this is a form that is best taken up by
the brain including the developing brain
it also has a good amount of astaxanthin
which protects the omega-3s from
oxidation and does the same for neurons
studies looking at DHA and EPA levels in
red blood cells have shown a correlation
between higher omega-3 status and having
a two centimeter larger brain volume
getting omega-3 into and keeping it in
the brain is definitely a brain aging
priority for me
the sauerkraut is a good source of
fermentable fiber also known as
prebiotics that is fuel for the
commensal gut bacteria so that they are
able to produce compounds such as short
chain fatty acids that feed more
commensal of gut bacteria and also feed
epithelial cells which required to make
the gut barrier these compounds produced
by the gut bacteria serve as signaling
molecules to make specific types of
immune cells an important indirect role
that fiber also has in the diet that
helps influence its immune activities
the sauerkraut itself contains the
various probiotics as well mostly the
lactobacillus strains which are
beneficial lactic acid producing
bacteria which have recently been
suggest to possibly play a role in
cancer prevention for dinner I usually
have some cooked vegetables like sauteed
space
which is very high in folate as are all
greens folate provides an important
precursor that makes a DNA nucleotide
called thymine every time you repair a
damaged cell or make a new cell on your
liver muscle brain etc you need to make
new DNA which means you need folate ful
it was also very recently shown to
increase the growth of stem cells which
is important because stem cell pulls
depleted with age and are a major cause
of organ aging and dysfunction bullet
has also recently been shown a player
while protecting telomeres the tiny caps
on the ends of chromosomes that are a
biomarker for age because they get
shorter every year a recent study showed
that mothers with the highest folate
levels had newborns with telomeres 10%
longer and every 10 nanograms per
milliliter increase in serum folate
levels newborns had a 5.8 percent
increase in telomere length which
actually suggests that maternal
nutrition may actually play a role in
determining the length of telomeres that
we have to start with sometimes instead
I'll have some collard greens bok choy
broccoli brussel sprouts parsnips of
course since all of these are
cruciferous vegetables I usually have
them with mustard powder sprinkled on
top since that provides an additional
source of myrosinase cruciferous
vegetables in general are among my
favorite types of vegetables to eat
because they contain isothiocyanates
associative studies have shown that the
top 20% of consumers of cruciferous
vegetables have a 22% reduction in all
cause mortality or instead I'll have a
big salad full of lots of different
greens which provide me with a
cornucopia of micronutrients including
folate magnesium calcium vitamin k1
lutein zeaxanthin and soulful queneau
votes which is a prebiotic that feeds
beneficial bacteria and gut and is found
in green vegetables
by the way salmon has a very low mercury
content with only 2 micrograms per 4
ounces cooked EPA as I mentioned earlier
in another question is a powerful
anti-inflammatory fatty acid that has
been shown to lower brain inflammation
as I mentioned earlier also DHA is a
critical component of all cell membranes
that makes up 30% of the fatty acids in
the brain or about 8% of the total
weight omega-3 fatty acids have recently
been shown to positively change gene
expression in several brain regions and
also generally shown to stave off brain
aging but also important is just not
dying people with the highest omega-3
fatty acid in
have been associated with having a 9%
reduced risk of all-cause mortality and
for each 1% increment in in omega-3
fatty acids in their blood
there was an associated 20% decrease in
risk for all cause mortality another
protein that I rotate for dinner is
chicken legs from pasture-raised chicken
which I like because in addition to the
protein I also get some cartilage which
is high in collagen protein glycine
which is interesting for reasons I
already discussed earlier sometimes
that's our the chicken bones and some
water with some spices and vegetables to
make chicken bone soup which gives me
all the same goodies I talked about with
hydrolyzed collagen powder chicken is
also very high in selenium which is a
cofactor for all glutathione related
enzymes and it's needed for them to work
it also has a modest amount of zinc
copper and iron finally I also sometimes
have a grass-fed fillet steak a few
times per month which is a good source
of vitamin b12 iron and zinc
approximately 16% of all menstruating
women are actually iron deficient for
the vegetarians out there it has been
recommended to take in about twice the
RDA for iron since iron which is bound
to phytate in plant sources is about two
times less bioavailable as I mentioned
earlier I also make a broccoli sprout
smoothie usually consisting of anywhere
between a hundred grams fresh weight or
sometimes a bit less of frozen since
freezing them actually increases the
sulfur vein content I do this about
three times a week usually I talked
about some of the interesting effects
that sulforaphane has on the brain but I
actually think that this might be in
some respects a compound versatile
enough to actually possibly even slow
the aging process in general we'll need
more studies to establish that fact but
I'm optimistic because of the already
numerous associative studies that have
shown in humans that high intake of
cruciferous vegetables have about a 40%
or 50% reduction in multiple types of
cancer ranging from bladder to breast
prostate to lung cancer but that's the
associative studies what gets me really
excited are the clinical studies on
Sulphur a frame that shows some pretty
amazing things for example men with
prostate cancer that were given 60
milligrams of stabilized sulforaphane
per day resulted in slowing the doubling
rate of a cancer biomarker known as
prostate specific antigen or PSA by 86%
compared to placebo which is pretty
amazing another really cool thing about
sulfur cream is that it activates
detoxification enzymes and caused our
bodies to excrete carcinogenic
pounds for example people that were
given a daily broccoli sprout beverage
containing around 262 milligrams of
glucose onon the precursor to
sulforaphane plus an additional 7
milligrams of sulforaphane increase the
rate of excretion of benzene by about
61% and a Kirlian by 23% beginning on
the first day of consuming the drink and
continuing throughout the entire 12 week
period of the trial benzene is a nasty
carcinogen that is known to cause cancer
in humans and animals particularly
leukemia some of the major sources of
benzene that people are exposed to you
are from automobile exhaust fumes and
air pollution and cigarette smoke
acrolein is found in most of the major
sources already mentioned for benzene
including air pollution but it is also
formed when carbohydrates proteins and
fats are heated so we get exposed to a
fair amount of acrolein from cooking our
foods so fur cream has also been shown
to improve markers of cardiovascular
health for example people with type 2
diabetes given 10 grams of broccoli
sprout powder per day for four weeks
lower their serum triglycerides by
around 19% and lowered their oxidized
LDL to total LDL cholesterol ratio by
around 14% and reducer after o genic
index by 50% which is a measure of
cardiovascular disease that incorporates
a wide variety of factors again pretty
amazing results for not changing
anything else in the diet or lifestyle
except adding sulforaphane to the diet
finally sulphur rain also lowered
inflammatory biomarkers and people with
type 2 diabetes who were given broccoli
sprout powder containing 40 milligrams
of sulfur referring for four weeks
reducing tnf-alpha by 11% boring
c-reactive protein by 16% I can tell you
from my own experience being involved in
clinical trials with unhealthy people
with metabolic syndrome it is very hard
to get drops in biomarkers of
inflammation after just one month with
no other dietary or lifestyle changes
the fact that sulfur Orion has such a
profound impact on lowering inflammation
is of great interest to me because it is
now believed that suppression of
inflammation is the single most
important driver of successful longevity
and that this actually increases
importance with advancing age and I
don't just mean living long either but
also a strong association with
capability meaning the ability to
adequately perform activities of daily
living as well as cognition in all
all major age groups including elderly
centenarians which are a hundred years
old
semi super centenarians which are 105 to
109 years old and super centenarians
which are a hundred and ten years old
and greater in fact inflammation has
been shown to be the single most
important predictor of cognitive
abilities surpassing its predictive
ability only by a person's quanta
logical age itself this Japanese study
that I'm referring to was a bit of a
surprise to me because several different
biomarkers were looked at including
blood glucose levels insulin sensitivity
and even telomere length but none of
those predicted successful aging in each
age group up to the super centenarians
low inflammation was the only predictor
of successful aging in all age groups so
now you know in a more comprehensive way
for those of you that have heard me
mention sulfur and a few times already
what's behind some of that to sort of
dive into some of the supplements that I
happen to be taking at this moment I'm
taking a multivitamin called won by a
company called pure encapsulations
people ask about the brand so I'm
sharing that I like this multivitamin
because it covers some of the bases for
various micronutrients that I just
talked about and also interestingly has
some trace elements including boron
which has been shown to reduce
double-stranded breaks accelerate wound
healing significantly increased mean
plasma free testosterone in a small
trial in men and increase the half-life
of vitamin D boron is definitely sort of
interesting and has caught my attention
recently the multivitamin I just
mentioned also has 2,000 IU's of vitamin
D so if I'm getting a lot of sunshine I
might leave it at that
or more often I'll add an additional
2,000 IU's of vitamin D I also usually
take around 135 milligrams of magnesium
citrate malate from thorn I usually try
to get most of my magnesium from foods
since it's a measure of how many greens
I'm getting even with my modest
supplementation I get a good bit but
around 45% of the u.s. population does
not have an adequate intake of magnesium
which for adults is roughly around 400
milligrams a day for a little
perspective one cup of cooked spinach
contains around 156 milligrams
I'll save a little bit magnesium for a
later discussion in a few moments but
it's really important another supplement
that I take every other day is vitamin
k2 which is found in fermented foods
particularly natto but also an organ
meat this is thought to be a good one to
take with vitamin jisun
both are involved in calcium homeostasis
I usually take around 100 micrograms in
the form of menaquinone otherwise known
as mk4 lastly as a part of the core
supplements I take daily is fish oil
which I actually take a lot of I usually
take to omega-3 phospholipid gel
capsules by Nordic Naturals which is
omega-3 isolated from herring roe
because the DHA is in a specific form
known as LIFO phosphoryl choline DHA
this form has been shown to be taken up
by the brain fest via the mfsb to a
transporter this is also the form you
can get if you get krill oil as well in
addition to this I also take four
capsules of Pro mega mm fish oil by
Nordic Naturals one of the key things to
know about fish oil is that it's one of
the supplements that you really need to
watch out for quality on it should be
kept refrigerated and you ideally want a
brand is trustworthy and not arriving to
already oxidized in fact varying degrees
official oxidation is of great concern
to the scientific community and
scientific study design when it comes to
fish oil because if researchers failed
to ensure the fish oil that they use in
their studies high quality weird mixed
results surrounding supplementation can
very well be expected this is a
characteristic that is sort of unique to
fish oil unfortunately what I like about
Nordic Naturals is that they are NSF
certified which is one of the
certifications for quality I mentioned
when responding to an earlier question
in addition to that my understanding
from having inquired is that they also
isolate their fish oil under nitrogen
conditions meaning no oxygen present so
as to minimize any oxidation during the
isolation process they are not by no
means you know the only option out there
but I felt pretty good about using their
products and I've used them for many
years okay a little bit more about the
fish oil habit I've taken fish oil daily
for about nine years now some of the
studies that kept me taking fish oil has
to do in particular with brain health
for example supplemental fish oil in
form of DHA 2 grams a day has been shown
to increase the clearance of amyloid
plaques in people with mild cognitive
impairment after 4 to 17 months but I
also take it because it has been shown
to slow the aging process in general for
example supplemental fish oil of 2.5
grams a day has been shown to slow
telomere shortening again which is a
biomarker for aging and lowers
biomarkers of oxidation and blood cells
in overweight middle-aged and older
adults
another study supplemental fish oil of
one gram a day increased muscle mass
hand grip strength upper and lower body
muscle strength and leg power and older
women after six months another studies
show that high-dose supplemental fish
oil of three grams a day increased
resting metabolic rate by 14% energy
expenditure during exercise by 10% and
the rate of fat oxidation during rest by
19% and during exercise by 27% at lower
triglyceride levels by 29% and increased
lean mass by 4% and functional path
capacity by 7% in healthy older females
there's also been studies that even show
it can affect the metabolic activity of
brown fat there are hundreds of studies
like these that have convinced me to
take fish oil daily but you get the
point moving on from fish oil I also
take the probiotics VSL number three
sachets either once a week or once every
two weeks I'll talk a bit more about
probiotics and this one in particular
when following up in another question I
mix in some other supplements like the
Mareva formulation of curcumin which I
already talked about earlier and I'm
also just starting to mix in a little
bit of nicotinamide right beside into
the mix nicotinamide right beside is the
form of vitamin b3 that gets converted
into nad which are already explaining
the importance of when I talked about
fasting but a brief recap nad status
improving is generally perceived as
one's benefits of fasting that improved
mitochondrial and metabolic function
declining nad status can be one of the
unfortunate negatives of the
inflammatory process nicotinamide rai
besides supplementation 100 milligrams
up to a thousand milligrams has been
shown to be safe in humans and increased
nad levels in a dose-dependent manner
with a thousand milligrams per day
raising nad levels up to 2 point 7 fold
over baseline there have been several
animal studies showing nicotinamide
ribose at improves mitochondrial
function improves mitochondrial
biogenesis muscle mass and metabolism
but this is an important easy-to-miss
point the doses that were given to
animals involved in studies were so high
that I'm afraid that the supplement I'm
taking right now which is by Thorne and
only has around 125 milligrams per
capsule won't quite cut it to meet some
of the robust results being seen in
these animal studies I think there is
still potential here but more studies in
humans definitely need to be done at
this point I'm still interested though
the last part of my weekly health
routine has to do with exercise I like
to mix up my weekly exercise routine
with aerobic exercise high intensity
training strength training and yoga and
ballet
sizes I usually do some form of exercise
every day even if it's only 15 minutes I
usually like to do a twenty to thirty
minutes on a session three times a week
but I recently moved and have not gotten
back into the Sano routine but I hope to
change that soon usually I go for about
a three-mile run about three times a
week
I'm not really an endurance athlete
clearly but I do enjoy it for the
cognitive boost it gives me whenever
have a big decision to make or something
that's causing me anxiety these are
times I'm especially enthusiastic about
going for a run
aerobic exercise has been shown to
increase the growth of new neurons in
the brain by twofold aerobic exercise
even starting in midlife has been shown
to almost completely reverse the
structural changes that occur in the
brain with aging it has been shown that
20 to 40 minutes of aerobic exercise can
increase serum drives brain-derived
neurotropic factor in healthy men by up
to 30% and similarly even 15 minutes of
aerobic exercise can increase them brain
derived neurotrophic factor albeit to a
lesser extent brain derived neurotrophic
factor robustly increases the growth of
new neurons in the brain and sort of
interestingly in the muscle it plays a
role in repairing damaged muscle it
combats brain atrophy which actually
begins at 20 years of age and by the
time a person reaches 100 if they do
they usually have lost on average about
20 percent of their brain mass brain
derived neurotrophic factor is also good
for combating brain atrophy by growing
new neurons it also has been shown to
help prevent neuropsychiatric disorders
like bipolar disorder schizophrenia
depression good stuff that you don't
want in short supply to try to get a
little bit of high-intensity workout
I'll do squat jumps for a few minutes at
a time high intensity training has been
trying to improve learning and memory
and when done for eight to twenty
minutes it increases the production of
neurotransmitters glutamate by 5% in
gaba by 7% as well as norepinephrine
which again is a catecholamine involved
in focus and attention interestingly the
production of norepinephrine is also
associated with the amount of lactate
generated from the high-intensity
workout a highly vigorous exercise
causes demand for energy to become too
high for the mitochondria to use glucose
or fatty acids to generate energy so
glucose is used as energy without the
mitochondria via a process called
glycolysis lactate is then produced as a
by-product
lactate is very similar to ketone bodies
and that it is transported to other
tissues including
brain heart liver utilizing the same
transporter known as the mono
carboxylate transporter which is used by
ketones then lactate is able to shunt
into the mitochondria to be used as an
energetically favorable source of energy
such as in the brain where can then be
used preferentially as a source of
energy by norepinephrine producing
neurons this idea that we can use
lactate possibly produced by our muscles
to help out brain tissue or other
tissues not responsible for its
generation is known as the lactate
shuttle theory which is an idea that was
pioneered by dr. George Brooks that
lactate produced by the muscles might be
used or shuttled elsewhere in addition
to squat jumps and running I also lift
some weights and do lunges and squats
with weights either two to three times
per week it is really important to
maintain muscle mass starting in
middle-aged people lose between 0.5 to
1% muscle mass per year one study
involving over 300 twins speaks the
importance of legs in particular greater
strength and power in the legs in
particular was associated with an
increased brain volume 10 years later
and less brain aging over 300 twins
other Fitness measures besides that of
legs such as forced expiratory volume or
grip strength were not associated with
brain aging when leg power was excluded
other lifestyle and health measures such
as frailty and telomere length also
indicated that reverse causation was not
likely so to get right down to it don't
skip leg day lastly I do some yoga and
ballet exercises three to four days a
week I really like to do these exercises
because they increase my flexibility and
tone very specific muscle groups I like
it but your mileage may vary
alright we're finally moving on to the
next question Russ
Sal himer asks what small change can you
make in your lifestyle that leads the
biggest impact on your health and
well-being essentially what is the 8020
of lifestyle changes okay so to
summarize Russ's question what 20% of
lifestyle inputs are leading to 80% of
the positive effects I think for people
starting from ground zero one of the
easiest lifestyle changes to make the
biggest impact on health is to cut out
refined sugar meaning any process
cookies cakes candies crackers drinks
etc refined sugar intake in the United
States is a big problem around 10
percent of adults in the United States
get around 25 percent or more of the
daily calories from added sugar and over
70% get at least 10% of daily calories
from added sugar it has been estimated
that consumption of sugar-sweetened
beverages in 2010 may have been
responsible for approximately a hundred
and thirty three thousand deaths from
type-2 diabetes
forty five thousand deaths from
cardiovascular disease and six thousand
four hundred and fifty deaths from
cancer worldwide let that sink in we're
not talking about smoking or alcoholism
we're not even talking about just sugar
in general we're talking about sugar
sweetened beverages by themselves but to
give an idea of some of the magnitude
effects that sugar consumption can have
in terms of sodas associative studies
have shown that adult Americans that
consumed roughly one can of soda per day
had a 46% higher risk of developing
pre-diabetes compared to low or non
consumers over the same 14-year period
in a similar vein another study showed
that replacing one sugar sweetened
beverage such as such a soda or
sweetened juice with water or
unsweetened coffee or tea reduces the
type two diabetes risk by up to 25% over
an 11-year period follow up dropping
refined sugar seems to also take effect
pretty quickly too in another study in
obese children that were put on a diet
with no added sugar for just 10 days it
was shown to decrease fasting blood
glucose by five points reduce insulin
levels by 1/3 and also improve
cholesterol and blood pressure cutting
out the refined sugar may be the single
easiest thing a person can do to
dramatically improve their health not
only is refined sugar associated with
higher risk of many diseases refined
sugar literally accelerates the aging
process itself healthy adults that drink
12 fluid ounces or roughly 1 can of soda
per day had much shorter telomeres in
their white blood cells than people the
same age but that do not drink soda
every day a reduction in telomere length
roughly equivalent to four point six
years of the biological aging telomere
length again is a well-established
biomarker for aging since our telomeres
get shorter every year and for that
reason it should be at least a little
alarming when you see an amount that is
equivalent of four point six years of
aging getting trimmed off inflammation
one of the factors that are very
important to aging may also be at play
here
one trial found that giving
the normal weight young men 20 ounces of
a sugar sweetened beverage that was more
or less similar to drinking a similar
amount of soda daily for three weeks was
enough to trigger an increase in the
biomarker of inflammation c-reactive
protein between 60 to 100 percent higher
than levels that they started with what
about hormones in one study men
experienced a 25% decrease in
testosterone for up to two hours after
75 grams of sugar intake there is
nothing good about consuming refined
sugar except for that short-lived
dopamine hit you experience which by the
way is also been shown that refined
sugar increases dopamine and activates
the brain's reward pathway in a way that
it some respects is very similar to
drugs like tobacco cocaine and morphine
it also effects the opioid system the
effects in terms of magnitude are
smaller than these substance abuse drugs
but the pattern ultimately follows a
similar trajectory you continually
activate the brain's reward system you
begin to lose self-control you start to
crave it and eventually build up a
tolerance to it so you need more and
more the same mechanisms are at play
when we talk about sugar addiction - in
my opinion the best thing you can do is
cut it out you will be so much healthier
by just cutting out this one thing once
you stop eating refined sugars foods
begin to actually taste sweeter that's a
really fact that's been shown in
clinical studies moving on the second
easiest thing that you can do that will
have a big impact on health is to begin
doing time restricted eating within a 9
to 12 hour time frame in accordance with
their circadian rhythm where unless you
are a night shift worker you try to eat
your meals earlier in the day as
possible like I discussed earlier if
you're looking to start out I think 10
hour is a very good middle-of-the-road
approach in fact I mentioned earlier
does a great job of establishing
magnitude of impact women that
previously had breast cancer and ate all
their food within an 11 hour time period
and changed nothing else in terms of
their dietary composition reduce their
breast cancer recurrence by 36% mindset
were fed a high sugar high fat diet that
could only eat within a 12-hour window
and still ate the same number of
calories as mice that were allowed to
eat within a 15 hour window ended up
being 28% leaner had 70% less body fat
did not get fatty liver compared to the
my splitting their meals over a longer
period of time which did end up with
fatty liver the
I'm restricted - also had better blood
glucose levels cholesterol profile and
were more active and can do more complex
motor tasks better this even included
two cheat days per week in which time
restriction wasn't in place to sort of
simulate a human weekend off it's really
important to drive home the fact that
the impact of time restricted eating was
made without other improvements in food
quality the versatility factor is a huge
benefit here and what makes it appealing
is it's broadly applicable for people so
that's - so far to answer this question
the big lifestyle inputs I've suggested
are remove all refined sugar is much
assumingly possible especially sodas and
implement time restricted eating
regardless of diet preferably earlier in
the day the huge third lifestyle import
that I think can make a big big
difference is simply doing whatever it
takes to potentially triple the amount
of vegetables you take in on a daily
basis for me the way I've gone about
this has been to make a habit out of
creating and micronutrients movie as
I've termed it basically I grab various
combinations of vegetables and sometimes
a few fruits to balance it out drop them
all into a powerful blender or food
processor and drink drink it down going
about it this way means that all that
hugely beneficial fiber still gets
ingested this is important because
commercial juicers remove the fiber
which is problematic since fiber is
highly beneficial for the microbiome
important for health and the regulation
of blood glucose levels and often in
short supply in the diet in the typical
Westerner we'll talk about the
implications of that and another
question that comes up later one
important tip is that using an
especially powerful blender make sure
that the smoothie has a consistent
texture enhancing the PAL ability of it
which may be a drawback for some folks
that may otherwise have preferred
juicing you learn over time adding
certain things like an avocado can
greatly change the structure usually
improving it having done this
micronutrients movie hack four to five
times per week for the past six years
often without regard of where it may fit
in with the rest of my diet even adding
it on top I noticed something pretty
interesting early on I noticed that the
amount of vegetables I was buying almost
quadrupled vegetables are a rich source
of many important micronutrients and
other compounds like lutein and
zeaxanthin they have important functions
that I mentioned earlier when talking
about the foods I eat the smoothie that
I make at the very least usually has
kale berries and avocado but I also like
to add chard and some other veggies like
carrots and
in the United States micronutrient
deficiencies are especially common but
this probably is true elsewhere abroad
as well
our das have been set to make sure
people meet their daily intakes but even
still people don't meet them some
micronutrients that are abundantly found
in greens just happen to be ones that
people in the United States are the most
efficient in somewhere around 45% of
people are deficient in magnesium 35% in
vitamin K 24% in vitamin C 34% in
vitamin A 38% in calcium in 8% in fully
magnesium because of its location at the
center of a chlorophyll molecule is
especially telling when it comes to the
root cause the problem a lack of
consumption of green leafies earlier I
mentioned that around 22% of all enzymes
require a micronutrient to function
these micronutrients are necessary for
metabolic pathways that are essential
for short-term survival and metabolic
processes that are important for
long-term health
sometimes these different processes both
require the same micronutrient to
function so what happens in a person
that happens to be inadequate or
deficient in that particular
micronutrient my former postdoctoral
mentor dr. Bruce Ames proposed that
those metabolic processes that are
required for short-term survival will
get their share of the micronutrient
first because nature wants you to
survive long enough to reproduce and
pass on your genes whereas processes
that are more concerned with the long
term maintenance processes involved in
mitigating Aging in the long term
ultimately get neglected Bruce calls
this evolved strategic rationing of
micronutrients the triage theory it's a
helpful way to think about how the body
deals with micronutrient adequacies and
deficiencies and he's published a couple
studies providing the theoretical
backing to support the idea while Nature
has devised this elegant way of
allocating vitamins and minerals to
ensure survival during periods of food
scarcity which has occurred throughout
evolution the trade-off is it results in
insidious types of damage that
accumulate with age accelerates the
aging process and leads to cancer and
nurture generation in the case of
magnesium over 300 different enzymes in
the body require magnesium including all
the enzymes that use and produce ATP
the energetic currency of the cell ATP
must be bound to a magnesium
Aion in order for it to be biologically
active these functions of magnesium are
required for short-term survival if you
can't make ATP you simply can't live but
the enzymes that are involved in the
generation of ATP are not the only
enzymes in the body that require
magnesium magnesium is also required for
enzymes that repair damage to DNA which
has been shown to lead to cancer and
damaged mitochondria which can
accelerate the aging process but optimal
DNA repair function is not critical for
short-term survival so those enzymes it
will logically follow would not get
their first pick of magnesium
putting aside the micronutrients for a
moment of course along with the kale you
also get some isothiocyanates like
sulfur frame which we talked quite a bit
about earlier finally for lifestyle
input number four the other really
really easy lifestyle change that I
think has a potentially big impact for
many many people is probably taking a
vitamin D supplement vitamin D is
actually converted into a steroid
hormone in the body and regulates around
five percent of the human genome let
that sink in and recall back to the fact
that approximately 70 percent of United
States population does not have adequate
levels of vitamin D which is an amount
of around 30 nanograms from milliliter
or greater or 75 nanomoles per liter if
your test uses that unit that means
around 70 percent of people in the
United States are experiencing some
dysregulation of their genes
due to poor vitamin D status as I
mentioned earlier this is largely due to
the fact that people are spending more
time indoors wearing sunscreen which
blocks out the ability of your skin to
make vitamin D people with darker skin
pigmentation moving to more northern
latitudes age etc earlier when
discussing vitamin D in the context of
serotonin production as a nootropic I
mentioned that I like my vitamin D
levels to be between 40 and 60 nano
grams per milliliter
here is part of the basis of that a
meta-analysis including around 30
studies from 1960 to 2013 showed that
people with vitamin D levels between 40
to 60 nano grams per milliliter has the
lowest all cause mortality and another
study found that people with those same
vitamin D levels had the longest hila
meters compared to age match controls
with lower vitamin D levels and sort of
just generally establishing again the
importance of vitamin D yet another
study involving a couple thousand twins
found that those with the lowest vitamin
D levels had shorter telomeres that
correspond to 5
years of accelerated aging vitamin D
activates the expression of DNA repair
genes anti-inflammatory genes and thus
lowers DNA damage and inflammation both
which accelerate the attrition of
telomeres so I think having adequate
vitamin D levels definitely has an
effect on long-term health but it also
affects short-term health as well a
meta-analysis of 25 randomized
controlled clinical trials conducted in
14 countries showed that vitamin D
supplementation cut infection risk by
50% in people that were deficient and by
10% in people with normal vitamin D
levels it also affects muscle mass and
exercise performance for example 2000 IU
of vitamin D per day for two weeks
increased exercise performance by 30
percent while lowering physical exertion
postmenopausal women receiving a vitamin
D supplement had a significant increase
about 25% in muscle strength while those
receiving the placebo actually lost an
average of around seven percent of
muscle mass there are so many studies
showing that vitamin D improves health
including brain health you do not want
to be deficient in it and yet so many
people are the solution is to take a
vitamin D supplement generally speaking
as a rule of thumb 1000 IU's of vitamin
d3 usually raises serum levels of
vitamin D by five nanograms per
milliliter this is sort of useful as a
course correction when you've got a
vitamin D test coming back outside of
the range you want to see it it really
is important however to measure your
blood levels of vitamin D after
supplementing as well okay so with that
last one I think that sort of wraps up
my high-level thoughts on lifestyle
strategy choices that might drive big
changes in a Pareto's principle sort of
fashion to recap number one eliminate
refined sugar from the diet to the
greatest extent possible number two
practice time restricted eating and eat
generally in accordance with your
circadian rhythm number three do
everything in your power to maximize
vegetable intake possibly using the
micronutrient smoothie method as a way
to jumpstart the habit number four
enlist your physician in helping you to
monitor your vitamin D blood status and
then attempting to titrate your dose to
an above 30 nano gram per milliliter
range possibly trying to land between 40
and 60 nano grams per milliliter and
then to sort of quickly add a number
four and number five number four try to
get some form of meaningfully vigorous
cardiovascular exercise at least 30
minutes a few times a week and number
five get bright blue light during the
day
as early as possible and avoid that same
blue light as much as you can in the
evenings all right if you're still with
me we're moving on to the next question
by Shawn Ballard Shawn asks Rhonda have
you considered taking meat completely
out of your diet
also which means do you consume where do
you get them and how frequently do you
consume meats the truth of the matter is
that there have been many many
correlative studies that have found that
higher meat consumption is associated
with a significantly higher risk of
cancer and cancer mortality this fact
alone should be enough to at least make
a person give thought to their position
on the subject especially when it's a
relationship that keeps showing up that
said one of the largest studies to date
which was published in in JAMA internal
medicine in 2016
looked at meat consumption and all cause
mortality and cancer related mortality
found something very interesting that is
very important to this narrative
specifically it found that a high intake
of meat from animal sources was only
associated with a higher mortality rate
and cancer mortality rate in people that
had at least one other factor associated
with an unhealthy lifestyle such as
being obese or having a history of
smoking or being physically inactive or
being a heavy consumer of alcohol meat
consumers that were healthy by not
having any of these after mentioned
unhealthy lifestyle factors did not have
a higher mortality rate or cancer
mortality rate critical to the meat
consumption in cancer link is the fact
that protein increases igf-1 something
that research suggests may be an
important link in this meat cancer
relationship earlier we talked a little
bit about the importance of igf-1 in
it's beneficial context for muscle
hypertrophy
but this cancer link is a trade-off
that's worth paying attention amino
acids and particularly essential amino
acids such as leucine which are more
abundant in meat are the most potent
dietary activators of the igf-1 pathway
igf-1 does a lot of stuff it's a growth
factor that plays a very important role
during early growth development and also
is important in promoting and
maintaining muscle mass as we discussed
and also neuronal function there are
many positive benefits to igf-1 but
there's also a trade-off as there so
often is in biology
igf-1 is a potent growth factor that
allows cells that have been damaged to
survive when they otherwise would die it
is important to understand that IGF
and does not cause damage to the cell
rather it allows damaged cells to live
and reproduce so that they can make more
copies of the damaged cells igf-1 is
known as a tumor promoter because it
promotes the growth of cancer cells
other factors that cause DNA damage such
as reactive oxygen species which are
byproducts of normal metabolism and
inflammatory cytokines which are
byproducts of the immune activation can
initiate cancer by causing DNA damage
which is the initial insult that can
lead to a damaged cell our body has a
protective mechanism that can sense that
damage and kill the cell but the
presence of an abundance of igf-1
overrides this mechanism and can allow
that damaged cell to survive this is why
igf-1 can be fuel for cancer growth not
initiation but growth that distinction
may be important as the pathway igf-1 is
actually a great interest in both cancer
and longevity research we know from
animal evidence that growth hormone and
igf-1 deficient mice are resistant to
cancer interestingly this evidence isn't
limited to animal research some humans
also have polymorphisms in the gene that
encodes for the igf-1 receptor which
leads to a decrease in igf-1 activity in
these individuals similar to animal
research we see a decreased incidence in
cancer and also longer lifespans
in these people human evidence also
exists for the exact opposite where
people that have genetic polymorphisms
that cause them to have increased igf-1
also have an increased cancer risk if we
get away from genetic polymorphisms and
look just at people with higher
circulating igf-1 in their serum
something that actually can be
quantified this awful has been
associated with an increased risk of
several different common types of
cancers including breast colon and
prostate so high igf-1 higher cancer
risk low igf-1 reduced cancer risk and
even longevity with this new
understanding of the relationship of
meat consumption to igf-1 production and
IGF one's relationship with cancer and
longevity where it even inhibits the
longevity genes FOXO 3 it would be very
tempting and very easy to take an
absolutist position and never touch meat
again putting aside all the other
reasons why someone might make such a
choice but as I mentioned earlier there
are good aspects to igf-1 igf-1 has been
shown to increase lean muscle and reduce
adipose tissue simultaneously at axes
under a trophic factor increasing the
growth of new brain cells
it prevents brain cells from dying it's
pretty clear that I actually want some
igf-1 activity I think this is a really
important take home with respect to
igf-1 because igf-1 has a good and a bad
side but I think exercise is a way to
tip the balance towards the good
exercise whether we're talking about
aerobic or resistance training has been
shown to lower serum igf-1 levels
because exercise causes our muscles to
take up igf-1
additionally igf-1 has been shown in rad
studies to cross the blood-brain barrier
in response to exercise and increases
neurogenesis this also means the
exercise lowers circulating
concentrations of igf-1 which means it
has less of a chance to promote the
growth of damaged cells or inhibit fox
or 3 and other tissues if we circle back
to the original study I mentioned where
meat consumption was only associated
with a higher all-cause mortality and
cancer mortality
if one other unhealthy lifestyle factor
was present this makes perfect sense if
most of the bad effects are mediated
through igf-1 since I do not have any of
those unhealthy lifestyle factors and I
understand what I perceived to be the
mechanism behind the relationship
between cancer and meat consumption I
have decided to keep some meat in my
diet
since they're already gone into a meal
breakdown where I talk about the meals I
eat in a typical week and another
question I'll skip to the last part of
this question which is where do I get my
meat from I usually get them from a
local grocery store or the farmers
market i buy wild fish mostly alaskan
salmon grass-fed beef and pasture raised
chicken with no antibiotics or hormones
okay on to the next question
Andrea Curlin asks I would like to hear
your thoughts on some of the fad diets
that have been circulating paleo
ketogenic vegetarian advocates of each
of these often claim that their diet is
the best for inflammation yet they are
all different I think there are benefits
to the perspectives that are brought by
each of these various philosophies
though there might be contexts that make
one or another make more sense I
personally choose a more middle of the
road route and eat what might be loosely
termed a paleo ish type of diet the good
news is that some of these diets have
aims that sort of overlap with one
another for example both paleo and
ketogenic style diets emphasize cutting
out refined carbohydrates and refined
sugar which in and of itself has a
dramatic effect on lowering inflammation
cancer risk cardiovascular disease risk
dementia risk and delays aging all of
which we talked about in more detail a
minute ago when discussing how cutting
out refined sugar is one of the big
changes a person can make to have a
rapid impact on personal health the
Paleo diet in contrast to some of the
popular cultures flavors of keto
emphasizes eating a lot of vegetables
and fruits which also comes with the
package and vegetarian diets as well as
I mentioned earlier fruits and
particularly vegetables are a great
source of micronutrients and other
important compounds such as folate
magnesium vitamin k1 calcium vitamin A
vitamin E vitamin C potassium lutein
zeaxanthin pterostilbene and the
sign-ins and other polyphenols and
flavonoids I already mentioned how
incredibly important these
micronutrients are how 22% of all
enzymes require some micronutrient to
work properly and how important they are
for metabolism mitochondrial function
neurotransmitter production antioxidant
and anti-inflammatory pathways immune
function brain function repair enzymes
basically everything important for
preventing disease and healthy aging one
of the problems with certain variations
of the ketogenic diet is that without a
great deal of care to avoid this pitfall
it can lead to inadequacies or
deficiencies in some of these
micronutrients and you may not get as
many of the other beneficial compounds
present in plants as well a great
example of this might be the flavonols
in blueberries just by way of example
fruits and vegetables which again it
seems the Paleo diet and vegetarian diet
focus a bit more on are also a great
source of various types of fiber
including fermentable fiber and non
fermentable fiber fiber is not a single
nutrient which is why fiber supplements
are no magic bullet either it's not just
about quantity but also diversity of
complex carbohydrates there are hundreds
of different polysaccharides which are
complex carbohydrates implants gut
microbes reflect this same diversity
specializing in using different types of
complex carbohydrates and even the
metabolic byproducts of the microbes
these microbes then produce short chain
fatty acids that impact our health in a
variety of ways this is why eating only
one type of fiber as in from
supplementation is ultimately a failed
strategy the best way to increase your
microbial biodiversity is to actually
eat a variety of polysaccharides from a
diverse diet
plants and vegetables as well as fruits
for example like mends and cellulose
which are found in plant cell walls are
non fermentable fiber that help move
food and other byproducts through the
intestines examples of fermentable fiber
that are eaten by a wide variety of
commensal bacteria in the gut include
pectins which are found in fruits and
berries gums which are found in seeds
inulin which are found in onions garlic
artichoke resistant starch which is
found in bananas and legumes green leafy
vegetables also contain a prebiotic
known as sulfur kono bows which also
feeds beneficial gut bacteria in the gut
in addition to diversity however we also
need volume of dietary fiber figuring
out what this golden amount is to keep
our microbes metabolically satisfied and
not literally starving is tricky the
Institute of Medicine recommends men
fifty years of age and younger get at
least 38 grams of fiber per day and
women fifty years of age and younger get
35 grams of fiber per day those numbers
drop slightly for adults older than 50
but traditional societies for example
those that exist in places like Tanzania
they are living a hunter-gatherer
lifestyle can get around 200 grams of
fiber compared to the norm for us which
is shockingly only about 15 grams per
day on average either by comparing to
traditional societies or just taking the
Institute of medicines recommendation
most people missed the mark it is
therefore important that whatever diet
you do choose you ultimately ensure your
microbiome has adequate substrate which
survives digestion to make it toward the
end that they just subtract or the
majority of these microorganisms live
and interact with our immune systems and
also our brains the big problem with a
low fiber diet which in the context of
this discussion may possibly be a
version of the ketogenic diet again
unless special care is taken is that it
may not provide this substrate fats
proteins and sugar are all absorbed in
the small intestine earlier on but all
of the hundreds of trillions of bacteria
that are in our gut and regulate our
immune systems brain function are more
at the end or the distal part of our
large intestine called colon when we eat
fiber deficient foods our gut microbes
starve but to keep from starving they
eat and cannibalize the gut barrier
which is made of carbohydrates and mucin
in terms of magnitude low-fiber has the
largest negative effect on breaking down
the gut barrier additionally one study
showed that a low fiber diet caused up
to a 75% depletion in half of the gut
bacterial species that's a magnitude of
effect that sounds almost on par with
actually taking a round of antibiotics
if you think about it okay so I avoid
some real concerns about possible
implementations of certain variations of
ketogenic diets but there are also many
other benefits of a ketogenic diet in my
opinion one of the main benefits from
the Kino genetic diet is a steady stream
of ketone body production particularly
beta-hydroxybutyrate
beta-hydroxybutyrate is a fascinating
mostly anti-inflammatory compound that
also plays an antioxidant again animals
linked to production of beta hydroxy
butyrate to lower oxidative stress lower
inflammation improvements in
mitochondrial respiration and ATP
production and improve brain function it
also may change gene expression in
positive way by regulating class 2
histone deacetylases as I mentioned
earlier in another question the
ketogenic diet has also been shown to
lower blood glucose levels and improve
insulin sensitivity and lead to weight
loss in some individuals but this is not
true for everyone as some people do
experience negative metabolic effects
likely due to genetic variation which is
why it may be helpful if you experiment
with this diet to keep an eye on some of
the blood biomarkers mentioned earlier
to make sure that if you do experiment
with it
you're not one of the folks that it may
not be ideal for in the long term it's
also possible to ramp up ketone body
projection for short bursts by kicking
off evening fasts a bit earlier playing
it strict and following some of the time
restricted eating or intermittent
fasting protocols out there going back
to the Paleo and vegetarian diets while
they both focus on eating whole
vegetables and fruits they obviously
differ in that vegetarian diets Lakme
and have even heavier emphasis on plants
obviously one potential drawback from
the vegetarian diet is that people on
this type of diet must put in a little
more effort to get some of the
micronutrients that are found in meat
such as the marine omega-3 fatty acids
EPA and DHA iron zinc vitamin b12
selenium for example iron which in
addition to being important for red
blood cells to carry oxygen to all
tissues is also required to produce
neurotransmitters in myelin non-meat
sources a
irons just kidney beans or lentils beans
contain iron that is bound to something
called fight ape there are large
bioavailability differences between iron
that is in heme which is how it is found
in meat
compared to iron that is in fight ate
from a plant source the bioavailability
of iron in fight eight is about 1.8
times lower than the iron and
bioavailability from heme the poor
bioavailability of iron that is bound to
phytate has to do with the fact that
humans cannot digest phytate so most
that iron does not get absorbed for this
reason the RDA for iron for vegetarians
should be 1.8 times higher the RDA for
adult males is about 8 milligrams a day
and for pre menopausal women about 18
milligrams a day
a lot of iron is lost during
menstruation which is why menstruating
women are a higher risk for deficiency
in iron in fact approximately 16% of all
menstruating women are iron deficient
too much iron however can cause serious
oxidative damage and other problems
which is why it's a good idea to get
iron levels measured instead of blindly
supplementing this is just one example
of what I mean by vegetarians having to
work a little harder and think about the
complexities like this to make sure they
get all other micronutrients there are
other examples a great one I mentioned
earlier are the omega-3 fatty acids it
may be tempting for vegetarians to just
dose up on conventional plant sources
like flaxseed some people have a gene
polymorphism in a gene that encodes for
the enzyme that converts the plant
omega-3 ala into EPA and DHA the ones I
refer to as a marine omega-3 fatty acids
a moment ago and this can cause them to
not convert as well as others this can
be circumvented by supplementing with
something like microalgae oil and
possibly eating higher concentrations of
ala however or you may just be lucky and
they have a highly efficient converter
of ala in which case it may not be a
problem similarly essential amino acids
are much more abundant in meat and maybe
something that vegetarians may need to
work a little harder to make sure they
are getting enough of particularly in
older age one study looking at people
over 65 years of age found that there
was an increased mortality rate with low
protein intake likely due to frailty as
I mentioned earlier starting mint in
middle age we lose about 0.5 to 1
percent of muscle mass a year and
essential amino acids are important for
maintaining muscle mass along with
putting those muscles to work of course
but if you recall earlier there may be a
flipside to that folks on a paleo or
keto diet do you include meat this means
that they may need to take special care
to be active and not sedentary to put
that igf-1 to use remember that eating
meat increases igf-1 and for people that
have even one component of an unhealthy
lifestyle such as being sedentary
smoking or excessive drinking or obesity
without trying to lose weight for
example paleo and keto diets both have
been shown to result in weight loss this
may increase all cause mortality and
cancer mortality so that is my sort of
high level general summary of these
three diets like I said I personally
choose to try to get the best of all
worlds
I eat paleo ish including fish and other
meats but with the big emphasis on
plants that otherwise might be more
common among vegetarian eat errs I am
very vigilant about avoiding refined or
processed foods especially refined sugar
I practice time restrictive eating and
intermittent fasting to get the
occasional dose of the ketone body
beta-hydroxybutyrate I do not smoke or
drink excessively I make sure to
exercise this protocol works really well
for me but there may be life context
being honest-to-god sedentary for
example or possibly even genetic
backgrounds in which we need to
emphasize one philosophy over the other
similarly a person might have an
important clinical reason for pursuing a
ketogenic diet in which case avoiding
pitfalls like poor micronutrient intake
can become especially important either
way I think there's a rich future in
figuring out where individual variation
and genetic polymorphisms come into play
in the pursuit of a healthy lifestyle
and conversely what approaches are more
broadly applicable like time restricted
eating okay on to the next question
Lukas Kovac asks do probiotics need to
be taken forever or do the different
strains of bacteria gain a foothold at
some point if I take probiotics for six
months and stop will it introduce colony
survive your question actually
highlights one of the important
drawbacks of taking supplemental
probiotics in order for probiotics that
are introduced to actually remain in the
colon which is where the majority of our
gut microbiome resides there has to be
space for these tiny microbes to stay
the predominant way bacteria take up
residence long term and the large
intestines is by sticking to the mucin
which is the mucus like material that
makes up the gut barrier and lines the
interior of the gut the problem is that
a person has just taken a course of
antibiotics that mucin is already
effectively colonized with bacteria that
already reside there which can be a
limiting factor that reduces the
foothold that new species are able to
gain what this effectively means is that
often probiotics that make up actually
make it to the colon if they were alive
when you took them end up being
flow-through instead of sticking around
but what's interesting however is that
probiotics can while passing through
facilitate population ships that may be
otherwise less than straightforward
while they pass through sort of like you
introduced population a and B but the
resident populations X is diminish and
resident population Y is increased or
alternatively the probiotics may also
interact more directly with our immune
system while they pass through basically
there's still a ton of research to be
done on probiotics it's clear that in
some cases they can be highly highly
effective for a variety of purposes but
sometimes the exact mechanism is a bit
elusive and may not be strictly
intuitive this issue of already being
colonized in existing biota taking up
space does however come with certain
obvious conclusions the first of which
is that if you're perhaps most advantage
in taking probiotics shortly after you
wiped out your existing population with
antibiotics it's important to note
however but the cumulative effect of
repeated use of antibiotics is pretty
much unambiguously negative from the
perspective of the gut microbial
communities with each additional course
causing even greater changes that shift
the community further away from its
natural starting state so it would not
be prudent to seek out antibiotics
strictly to try to liberate a little
space in the gut interestingly another
time to take them may be while taking
antibiotics to clinical studies have
shown that this can reduce the potential
of later c diff infections among other
things got researcher dr. justin
Sonnenberg at a Stanford has
characterized probiotics with potential
placeholders that prevent pathogens from
gaining a foothold during recovery which
may be an interesting way to look at it
however with that said it is possible
that was repeated use as is the case
with six months that some can get a
foothold in the mucin and stick there to
have a better chance of that happening
or having any sort of therapeutic effect
at all it's helpful to first have a
product that your
confident is alive when it arrives to
you and also has a sufficient quantity
of bacterial cells it can actually make
an impact there's one particular product
that stands out for this reason and also
because of the sheer volume of clinical
evidence that you can find by just
searching its name in Google Scholar or
PubMed the product to which I'm
referring to is known as VSL number
three particularly the unflavored
sachets which has 450 billion probiotics
per serving packet they also get shipped
in an actual cooler with ice packs to
ensure they're viable when they get to
you by way of comparison you might be
lucky to find a probiotic with 100
billion but most contain more like 10
billion or sometimes even less and the
viability of those bacterial cells by
the time it makes it off the shelf or
out of the warehouse into your
refrigerator may or may not be
effectively zero there are also dozens
of publications showing the
effectiveness of DSL number three both
in humans and animals looking at its
effect on a wide variety of conditions
ranging from the more obvious like
antibiotic induced diarrhea but also its
effect on insulin signaling
atherosclerosis food allergy colitis
liver dysfunction lipid profiles blood
pressure and more but to speak to Luke's
question about whether species and
probiotics are able to gain a foothold
I have anecdotally measured in both mine
and my husband's microbiome species
using a consumer service both before and
after taking BSL number three for
several months and did find that the BSL
number three cause new species of a
commensal bacteria to crop up that were
not quantifiable at my baseline and
we're not even species necessarily found
in BSL number three I think it is
possible that some of the probiotic
strains that were in the BSL number
three produced what are known as short
chain fatty-acids small molecules like
lactate which then ultimately provide
fuel for other neighboring strains of
bacteria that I may have had in very
small quantities already present in my
gut which then became more detectable
once they sufficiently increased in
quantity so this sort of feeds into that
earlier discussion about how probiotics
can have positive effects but then when
you go and actually look at the changes
from the probiotics that may be somewhat
unexpected additionally in my experience
some of the strains actually present in
the super probiotic base the number
three did begin to show up as well all
of that said as a person with former gut
problems that seem to have been resolved
I know
take VSL number three every day because
frankly it is a bit cost prohibitive and
probably not even necessary for me at
this point instead I take a maintenance
dose every week or so and generally keep
what I consider an airtight diet that
promotes a healthy microbiome through
the consumption of an abundance of
various types of healthy for mental
fiber if you're listening to this and
look up the asana 3 online again no
affiliation here
be aware that it can be bought direct
from the manufacturer and shipped to
your home without a prescription but
they do advertise it as a medical food
with the expectation that you're taking
it under the care of a physician so
while I don't know of any particular
risk from taking probiotics it's always
good to follow the prudent podcast
listeners rule and consult a physician
who are trying to treat what may be a
medical condition the next question is
from Mary Maxie who asks our artificial
sweeteners bad for gut health or overall
health
should they be avoided I try to avoid
them because they may have adverse
effects on gut health and through that
overall health too once in a while it's
probably fine for it but for everyday
use as the case with daily diet soda
it's not a good idea in my opinion there
was a study published in 2015 that
showed that artificial sweeteners alter
the gut microbiome both in mice and in a
small group of human trial participants
in the mice they tested saccharine
sucralose and aspartame and found that
they increase the population of bacteria
that are better at extracting energy
specifically glucose from food and then
store that energy is fat this ultimately
altered gene expression which then
allowed for increased fat storage and
decreased fat burning similarly humans
that were given a high dose of saccharin
showed a rapid alteration of the gut
microbiome and also had decreased
glucose tolerance sort of showing a
proof that the same mechanism in mice
does seem to crossover when we're
talking about people to this sort of
hints at a potential bitter irony
whereby people having switched to
drinking diet sodas for example may
actually be affecting their microbiome
in such a way as to actually make
themselves more obese even if the empty
sugar calories they're taking in have
been reduced in general if we think
about overall health putting aside
whether the effects mediated by the
microbiome or not artificial sweeteners
in particular have been linked to
metabolic syndrome coronary heart
disease and other cardiovascular
I'm somewhat optimistic that the effects
of the natural non-nutritive sweeteners
stevia are somewhat more benign
especially in light of a 2016 study that
showed lipid improvements and even
therapeutic potential in a rodent model
of obesity this sort of hints at the
fact that it may be a totally different
can of worms but even so I still think
that it's worth exercising some degree
of caution in general when talking about
artificial sweeteners or even the
non-nutritive sweeteners stevia proper
randomized control trials are lacking
I'm sure the debate will continue until
these sort of gold standard trials
emerge that can move a conversation
forward by firming up the details more
for now I personally avoid artificial
sweeteners altogether and only use
stevia in moderation
the next question is by Emily st. Clair
who asks is metformin really damaging to
the mitochondria or is it more of a
hermetic stressor briefly for those who
do not know what metformin is but
Foreman is a drug specifically a
biguanide derivative that is primarily
used for the treatment of type 2
diabetes it helps control blood glucose
levels and restore insulin sensitivity
it decreases the amount of blood sugar
that the liver produces mostly through
producing gluconeogenesis in the liver
via a NP kinase activation it also
reduces the amount of glucose at the
intestines or stomach absorbed in
addition to affecting blood glucose
metformin effects other pathways
involved in metabolism inflammation and
growth that said the reason why Emily
may be asking this question if I were to
venture a guess is because over the last
few decades there have been several
hints that metformin in addition to
regulating blood sugar and people with
type 2 diabetes might also prevent
diseases associated with aging in the
late 1990s a study in the UK found that
type 2 diabetics taking metformin
lowered all diabetes-related
complications by 32% and also lowered
the risk of cardiovascular disease other
studies have found that taking metformin
is associated with the reduced cancer
risk and it also preserved cognitive
function but the study that got the most
attention and certainly piqued my own
interest was a British study involving
around 78,000 individuals that found
that adults with type 2 diabetes who
took metformin on average live longer
than healthy age match controls that was
kind of mind-blowing for me
oddly enough among the many
compounds that have been shown to affect
lifespan and animals including metformin
rapamycin resveratrol and others
metformin has generally not been that
impressive but metformin does have a
long reassuring track record since
people with type 2 diabetes have been
taking it since the 1960s still I don't
take it but I'm interested for its
future and we'll be keeping an eye on
emerging research to more directly
answer the original question metformin
does inhibit complex one of the
mitochondrial respiratory chain which is
a very important complex in the
mitochondria that is responsible for
energy production and thus inhibits
oxygen consumption in the mitochondria
believe it or not several researchers
actually think that this may be an
important mechanism by which men Foreman
affects aging this is because by
inhibiting the mitochondria this turns
down mitochondrial metabolism which may
mean the mitochondria accumulate less
damage since they aren't working as hard
the consequence of complex one
inhibition by metformin is a decline in
ATP production and an increase in adp
and ANP production and this activates an
P kinase so far as I am aware the
complex one inhibition in mitochondria
does not appear to cause mitochondrial
toxicity future studies will help better
illuminate if and how metformin can
reliably extend human health span and
whether or not this doesn't come with
some sort of drawback that just hasn't
been teased out yet okay on to the last
question Sara Fox asks for superior
health do you recommend to stay away
from any alcohol or are an occasional
couple glasses of red wine on the
weekends okay Sara you and indeed
probably Tim will be relieved to know
that I think a couple of glasses of red
wine on weekends are probably okay okay
having answered my last question I want
to give a big huge gigantic things to
Tim for having me back on the show it's
been an enormous privilege that I'm just
extremely grateful for I'd also like to
give a special thanks to those of you
that I submitted some really fantastic
questions that show an amazing amount of
attentiveness to some of my pet passions
and of course thank you the person
listening right now whoever you are for
listening your time and attention means
something to all of you keep being
awesome
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or the Nexen pondering over the
week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by wordpress
my go-to platform for blogging writing
online creating websites everything I
love WordPress to bits
my site every site just about that I
have is run on WordPress and the lead
developer of WordPress Matt Mullenweg
has appeared on this podcast many times
the very first episode in particular is
amazing the second I took a ton of notes
on so you should check it out but
WordPress where do I even begin I mean
the New Yorker uses it jay-z Beyonce
they use it 5:38
TechCrunch Ted CNN time whether you are
looking to create a personal blog a
business site both neither something
else you'll make a huge impact when you
build your website on wordpress.com and
directly from some friends at Google I'm
not going to quote them by name but they
say that WordPress offers the best
out-of-the-box SEO the search engine
optimization imaginable so if you're on
WordPress you immediately have a leg up
on everybody else on search engines and
so forth in my experience
no medical doctor of search engine
optimization but I will say that I used
WordPress for years and fell in love
with it to the extent that I became very
close friends with Matt and then became
an investor slash advisor to automatic
which runs WordPress calm that is how
much I believe in this and that's how a
lot of my most successful products and
investments have come about because I'm
in love with X and then I seek out
stacks nearly 30% of the Internet is run
on WordPress and that includes
everything from the huge sites that I
mentioned to neighborhood sites and it
is super easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security or upgrades
or hosting they offer 24/7 support and
handle all of that which allows you to
focus on creating the highest quality
content you can with the least amount of
friction I don't have to worry about
downtime I don't have to worry about
getting emergency emails if I'm on
vacation or something like that and
WordPress is my go-to solution for all
of this I trust all of my most important
text on the Internet to WordPress and
they can't buy that with a sponsorship
they can't buy that with anything I want
uptime uptime uptime and quality and
that is what I have selected after
everything that I've looked at so check
it out go to WordPress that's wor DP re
SS com wordpress.com forward slash Tim
to receive 15% off of your website today
that's wordpress.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
Alibaba
and the Gateway 17 event this is very
cool so listen up if you are an
entrepreneur or a business owner in the
United States the stars don't always
align that this might get closed all
right the opportunity is this the
gateway 17 event which 17 is 2017 is
hosted by Alibaba and Alibaba if you
don't know it you could think of as a
combination of Amazon and Google in
China it is huge this event is designed
specifically to help you guys
tap into the 500 million consumers in
the Chinese market they're fast growing
middle class is larger than the entire
US population
Holly Bob has created a marketplace
better technology to help you connect
the people you want to connect with this
is 500 million and now they were looking
for us-based businesses to fill the
demand the Gateway 17 event is designed
to help match make and educate you
teacher everything you need to know the
speakers include Jack Ma who is the
founder of Alibaba he has an estimated
net worth of more than twenty billion
dollars this is his only speaking
appearance in 2017 David Abney the CEO
of ups Charlie Rose and more it's a
two-day event it's in Detroit Michigan
June 20 and 21st and it puts you in
direct contact with experts who want to
help you grow your business specifically
to access the 500 million in China and
is a listener of this podcast there is a
very legit offer which more sponsors
would offer this type of discount
Alibaba is offering you the normal
tickets which are $500 for one hundred
and twenty five dollars that is a 75%
discount if you sign up by May 25th so
if you sign up by May 25th you can get a
$500 ticket for $125 if you use the code
Tim at checkout that's capital T
lowercase I M you might have to try all
lowercase or all caps but to start with
capital T lowercase I am check it out
just the website alone teaches you a lot
about the Chinese middle class and this
new consumer base which has incredible
purchasing power I happen to know a
decent amount about it go to gateway 17
calm that's gateway the number one seven
calm and enter the code him at checkout
that's gateway 17 dot-com there are a
limited number of spots and it is a low
cost event with potentially very very
high upside for the right folks check it
out
gateway 17 calm and use code him
you
[Applause]